Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The remote Shire of Sandstone sits roughly 715 kilometers northeast of Perth in the heart of the Murchison district. Once a thriving gold mining town, by 2015 Sandstone had a population of less than 90 residents. While some outsiders still venture there to try their luck on the goldfields,
我们的剧集涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集节目的说明。偏远的桑德斯通郡位于珀斯东北约715公里处，地处默奇森区的中心地带。桑德斯通曾是一个繁荣的金矿小镇，到2015年，其人口已不足80人。虽然仍有一些外来者冒险前往那里，试图在金矿区碰碰运气，
more are drawn by the natural beauty and outback charm of the area. At night, the rugged red terrain gives way to uninterrupted sky views, providing tourists with unforgettable sunsets and world-class stargazing. Many visitors to Sandstone choose to camp in the surrounding outback, but those seeking greater creature comforts have the option of staying at the Caravan Park, conveniently located in the centre of town. On Saturday March 28, 2015, the park's manager, Caroline Cramp, noticed an unfamiliar presence wandering through the grounds. It was an ageing black and white Great Dane that appeared hungry, as though she hadn't eaten for several days. Caroline approached the dog with a bowl of water. She thirstily accepted.
但更多人是被该地区自然风光和内陆魅力所吸引。夜晚，崎岖的红色地形让位于一览无余的天空，为游客提供了难忘的日落和世界级的观星体验。许多到访桑德斯通的游客选择在周边的内陆地区露营，但那些寻求更舒适生活条件的人可以选择住在位于镇中心的房车公园。2015年3月28日星期六，公园经理卡罗琳·克兰普注意到一个陌生的身影在场地内徘徊。那是一只年迈的黑白相间的大丹犬，看起来很饿，好像已经好几天没吃东西了。卡罗琳端着一碗水走近这只狗。它渴极了，接受了水。
Despite being tired and a little on the thin side, it was clear to Caroline that the dog was domesticated. She was friendly, wore a collar and appeared to be well taken care of with no blisters or burns at the bottom of her paws. Caroline spent the next two days looking after the dog, expecting that her owners would show up to claim her. When nobody did, Caroline contacted the local shire and gave them the registration number on the dog's tag. They identified the Great Dane to be named Ella. Her owners, Ray and Jenny Kellett, were registered as living in Beverley, a country town 710 kilometres south of Sandstone. Calls were placed to both Ray and Jenny's mobile phones. Neither of them answered. 47-year-old Ray Kellett and his wife, 49-year-old Jenny, had adopted Ella from the Great Dane
尽管很累且有些消瘦，但卡罗琳很清楚这只狗是家养的。它很友好，戴着项圈，看起来被照顾得很好，爪子底部没有水泡或烧伤。卡罗琳花了接下来的两天时间照顾这只狗，期待它的主人会出现认领它。当没人出现时，卡罗琳联系了当地郡政府，并提供了狗牌上的注册号码。他们确认这只大丹犬名叫埃拉。她的主人雷和珍妮·凯莱特登记居住在贝弗利，这是一个位于桑德斯通以南710公里的乡村小镇。他们拨打了雷和珍妮的手机。两人都没有接听。47岁的雷·凯莱特和49岁的妻子珍妮，于2009年从西澳大利亚大丹犬
Lovers Association of Western Australia in 2009. A rescued breeding dog with a history of being mistreated, the Kellets were able to offer Ella the good life she deserved. The couple lived on a 150-acre hobby farm just outside of Beverley where they raised cattle and sheep and grew their own herbs and vegetables. Although Ella had plenty of space to run around, she mostly chose to stay by Ray and Jenny's sides. The couple had met in 2004 and they'd been inseparable ever since. Both were divorced with children from their previous marriages, Jenny with three kids and Ray with two. With a mutual love for the outdoors and a shared passion for working on their farm,
爱好者协会领养了埃拉。作为一只曾受虐待的获救繁殖犬，凯莱特夫妇能够给埃拉她应得的美好生活。这对夫妇住在贝弗利郊外一个150英亩的业余农场里，他们在那里饲养牛羊，并种植自己的草药和蔬菜。虽然埃拉有足够的空间四处奔跑，但她大多选择待在雷和珍妮身边。这对夫妇于2004年相识，此后便形影不离。两人都离过婚，并各自有前一段婚姻的孩子，珍妮有三个孩子，雷有两个。由于对户外活动有着共同的爱好，对经营农场有着共同的热情，
Ray and Jenny were described as being laminated together. Ella became like their shadow. Wherever Ray and Jenny went, Ella went too. Therefore, when Ray's daughter Melanie received a call from the council on Tuesday March 31 2015, saying that Ella had been found wandering alone at the Sandstone Caravan Park, she immediately knew something was wrong. Melanie sometimes helped take care of Ella, and she'd been listed on her registration in case of emergency. She tried calling Ray and Jenny but with no success. She then called Jenny's daughters, who immediately shared Melanie's concerns. They all knew how attached Ray and Jenny were to Ella.
雷和珍妮被形容为“像层压板一样粘在一起”。埃拉成了他们的影子。无论雷和珍妮去哪里，埃拉也跟着去。因此，当雷的女儿梅兰妮在2015年3月31日星期二接到议会打来的电话，说埃拉被发现独自在桑德斯通房车公园徘徊时，她立刻意识到出事了。梅兰妮有时会帮忙照顾埃拉，她的名字也被列在埃拉的注册信息中以备紧急情况使用。她试着给雷和珍妮打电话，但没有成功。随后她给珍妮的女儿们打了电话，她们立刻分享了梅兰妮的担忧。她们都知道雷和珍妮有多么依恋埃拉。
If they'd become separated from her for any reason, they'd be doing everything in their power to get her back. The fact that they'd made no apparent attempt to do so was a major red flag for the families. The last any of them had spoken to Ray and Jenny was 13 days prior on Wednesday March 18. The couple had mentioned they were going on a gold prospecting trip out near Sandstone and they planned to return in early April. They said they'd be unreachable for about 10 of those days because they'd have no mobile phone reception for the bulk of the trip. Nothing about this was out of the ordinary for Ray or Jenny. They were both avid, experienced campers who spent a majority of their spare time outdoors.
如果他们因为任何原因与她分开了，他们会尽一切努力把她找回来。事实上，他们显然没有做出任何尝试，这对家人来说是一个重大的危险信号。他们最后一次与雷和珍妮通话是在13天前的3月18日星期三。这对夫妇提到他们要去桑德斯通附近进行一次黄金勘探之旅，并计划在四月初返回。他们说在那大约10天的时间里他们将无法联系，因为在大部分行程中他们都没有手机信号。对于雷或珍妮来说，这并没有什么异常。他们都是狂热且经验丰富的露营者，大部分业余时间都在户外度过。
Avid experienced campers who spent a majority of their spare time outdoors. Prospecting was a new hobby of theirs and they'd been excitedly preparing for the trip for months. Ray and Jenny had been secretive about where exactly they were heading, which was nothing unusual for prospectors. Their research had led them to believe there were hopes of finding gold at their intended site and they wanted to keep the location under wraps. Ray and Jenny had left their families the number for a satellite telephone they could call in case of emergency. One of their daughters dialed the number. A male answered, but it wasn't Ray. It was Graham Milne, an older co-worker of Ray and Jenny's. The trio worked together at Cloudbreak, a fly-in, fly-out mining site in the Pilbara region of Western Australia, and it was through Graham that Ray and Jenny had developed an interest in prospecting. For the past few months, he'd been teaching them the basics in preparation for the trip.
狂热且经验丰富的露营者，大部分业余时间都在户外度过。勘探是他们的一项新爱好，他们已经为这次旅行兴奋地准备了几个月。雷和珍妮对他们具体要去哪里守口如瓶，这对于勘探者来说并不罕见。他们的研究使他们相信在预定地点有发现黄金的希望，他们想对这个地点保密。雷和珍妮给家人留了一个卫星电话号码，以便在紧急情况下联系他们。其中一个女儿拨打了这个号码。一名男子接听了，但不是雷。他是格雷厄姆·米尔恩，雷和珍妮的一位年长同事。这三人曾在西澳大利亚皮尔巴拉地区的Cloudbreak矿区一起工作，这是一种“飞进飞出”的矿场，正是通过格雷厄姆，雷和珍妮才对勘探产生了兴趣。在过去的几个月里，他一直在教他们基础知识，为这次旅行做准备。
Graham Milne said that he'd joined the Kellets for the first leg of their prospecting trip. They'd set up camp at Bell Chambers, a remote area 30 kilometres south of Sandstone. Graham had only stayed for a few days because he was due back at work, but he said Ray and Jenny had plans to travel onwards after he was gone. Graham said he'd departed the camp in the early hours of Sunday March 22 while Ray and Jenny were still sleeping. He hadn't heard from either of them since. He hadn't heard from either of them since. The closest police station to Sandstone was 155 kilometres west in the town of Mount Magnet. Ray and Jenny's family immediately contacted the station to file a missing persons report.
格雷厄姆·米尔恩说他加入了凯莱特夫妇的勘探之旅的第一阶段。他们在贝尔钱伯斯扎了营，这是一个位于桑德斯通以南30公里的偏远地区。格雷厄姆只待了几天，因为他必须回去工作，但他表示雷和珍妮计划在他离开后继续前行。格雷厄姆说他在3月22日星期日凌晨离开了营地，当时雷和珍妮还在睡觉。此后他再也没有收到过他们的消息。此后他再也没有收到过他们的消息。距离桑德斯通最近的警察局位于西边155公里的芒特马格内特镇。雷和珍妮的家人立即联系了该警局提交失踪人口报告。
Although they had very little information about where the couple could be, the Constable on duty contacted the Shire of Sandstone and advised council workers to be on the lookout for Ray and Jenny, who were driving two vehicles between them, an old beige Land Cruiser Ute and a new black Land Rover Discovery. Both vehicles were towing trailers, one of which contained a red quad bike. But two council workers were already onto it. One of them had seen Ella a week earlier in an area known as Bell Chambers, a five kilometre stretch of flat ochre desert pockmarked with old mineshafts, trenches, mulga trees, and saltbush. Ray had also previously contacted the council seeking information about the area, so this
尽管他们关于这对夫妇可能在哪里几乎没有任何信息，但值班警员联系了桑德斯通郡，并建议议会工作人员留意雷和珍妮，他们驾驶着两辆车，一辆旧的米色陆地巡洋舰皮卡和一辆新的黑色路虎发现者。两辆车都拖着拖车，其中一辆装有一辆红色四轮摩托车。但两名议会工作人员已经开始行动了。其中一人一周前在被称为贝尔钱伯斯的地方见过埃拉，那是一片五公里长的平坦赭色沙漠，布满了旧矿井、沟渠、金合欢树和盐灌木。雷之前也曾联系过议会询问有关该地区的信息，所以这
seemed like a good place to start. The council workers headed out to bell chambers and soon came across a group of campers who pointed them towards a campsite they believed might belong to the Kelletts. The council workers promptly located the campsite, which was set between a low granite outcrop and a creek bed. Ray and Jenny's two vehicles were there, along with what looked like a typical camp set up. There was a trailer top tent, a washing line with clothing hanging on it, a table containing a dirty frying pan and unfinished cups of coffee. But when the council workers got out to take a closer look, they noticed some unusual details.
似乎是一个很好的起点。议会工作人员前往贝尔钱伯斯，很快遇到了一群露营者，他们指引他们前往一个他们认为可能属于凯莱特夫妇的营地。议会工作人员迅速找到了营地，营地位于一个低矮的花岗岩露头和河床之间。雷和珍妮的两辆车都在那里，还有看起来像是典型的露营布置。有一个拖车顶帐篷，一根挂着衣服的晾衣绳，一张桌子上放着一个脏平底锅和没喝完的咖啡杯。但当议会工作人员下车仔细查看时，他们注意到了一些不同寻常的细节。
Untouched food, including a rancid slab of meat, sat out in the open. A portable fridge was no longer cold and its contents were spoiled. The council workers approached Jenny's Land Cruiser. The doors were unlocked and the keys were still in the ignition, but there was no sign of Jenny or Ray. They turned their attention to Ray's new Land Rover. This too was unlocked with the keys in the ignition. Some of the windows were slightly ajar and the interior was wet from the recent rain. On the right hand door handle was a wasp nest which
未动过的食物，包括一块变质的肉，放在露天。一个便携式冰箱不再制冷，里面的东西已经变质。议会工作人员走近珍妮的陆地巡洋舰。车门没锁，钥匙还在点火开关里，但没有珍妮或雷的踪迹。他们将注意力转向雷的新路虎。这辆车也没锁，钥匙在点火开关里。一些窗户微微敞开，车内因最近的雨水而潮湿。在右侧门把手上有一个黄蜂巢，
looked like it had only recently been built. Inside the vehicle on the back seat were two firearms. One was in its case while a.22 Magnum rifle sat in the open loaded and wet from the rain. Clothes and cartons of cigarettes were also strewn around to the back seat. While it looked as though the campsite had been unoccupied for some time, nothing found there raised any alarm. It looked like its occupants had simply abandoned it all of a sudden. The council workers used a satellite phone to inform the constable what they'd found. He advised them to take the firearms back to Sandstone so they could be secured. The council workers then wrote a note for Ray with their
看起来是最近才筑好的。车内后座上有两支枪。一支在枪套里，而一支.22马格南步枪则敞开着，装了子弹且被雨水淋湿了。衣服和几盒香烟也散落在后座上。虽然看起来营地已经有一段时间没人了，但那里发现的东西并没有引起任何警觉。看起来居住者只是突然放弃了这一切。议会工作人员用卫星电话通知警员他们发现了什么。他建议他们把枪支带回桑德斯通以便妥善保管。议会工作人员随后给雷写了一张便条，上面留下了他们的
contact details on it, explaining why they'd taken his guns and left it on his dashboard. They had a quick look around the surrounding area, calling Ray and Jenny's names and peering down some of the nearby mineshafts. Finding nothing of note, they headed back into town. By this point, it was after 5pm and starting to get dark. At the advice of the Western Australia Police Emergency Operations Unit, who specialise in land-based search and rescue operations, the police decided not to visit the site unless Ray and Jenny still hadn't returned to the camp by daybreak. A Mount Magnet Police Constable arrived at Bell Chambers the next morning of Wednesday April 1 and confirmed there had
联系方式，解释了他们为什么要拿走他的枪，并把它留在了仪表盘上。他们在周边地区快速看了一圈，呼喊着雷和珍妮的名字，并向附近的一些矿井里窥视。没有发现任何值得注意的东西，他们便回到了镇上。此时已经是下午5点多，天开始黑了。在西澳大利亚警察紧急行动小组（专门从事陆地搜救行动）的建议下，警方决定除非雷和珍妮在天亮前还没回到营地，否则不前往现场。一名芒特马格内特警员于次日4月1日星期三抵达贝尔钱伯斯，并确认
been no recent movements at the campsite. However, they'd received some interesting information overnight. The group camping nearby had informed the council workers that a red quad bike appeared to have been abandoned approximately 500 metres north of the Kelletts campsite. They'd noticed it when they first arrived in the area on Friday March 27, and it hadn't moved since. The quad bike was located and confirmed as belonging to Ray Kellett. It was parked two-thirds up the side of a small hill facing away from the campsite and partially hidden amongst bushland. There were no keys in the ignition or any fresh tracks to suggest it had
营地最近没有任何动静。然而，他们连夜收到了一些有趣的信息。附近露营的一群人告诉议会工作人员，一辆红色四轮摩托车似乎被遗弃在凯莱特营地以北约500米处。他们在3月27日星期五刚到达该地区时就注意到了它，从那以后它就没动过。四轮摩托车被找到并确认为属于雷·凯莱特。它停在一个小山坡的三分之二处，背对着营地，部分隐藏在灌木丛中。点火开关里没有钥匙，也没有任何新鲜的痕迹表明它在
been driven in the past few days. It was still filled with petrol and showed no obvious damage to indicate why the driver would have suddenly abandoned it. obvious damage to indicate why the driver would have suddenly abandoned it. The constable conducted a cursory search of the Kellett's campsite. Inside Ray's glove box was Ray's wallet. It contained multiple cards, but no cash. Whatever had happened to Ray and Jenny, the state of their campsite indicated that they hadn't intended to be gone for long. It was theorised that they could have gotten lost while out prospecting, or had fallen down
过去几天里被驾驶过。它仍然加满了汽油，没有明显的损坏迹象表明驾驶员为什么要突然放弃它。驾驶员为什么要突然放弃它。警员对凯莱特夫妇的营地进行了粗略的搜查。雷的杂物箱里有雷的钱包。里面有多张卡，但没有现金。无论雷和珍妮发生了什么，他们营地的状况表明他们并不打算离开太久。有人推测他们可能在勘探时迷路了，或者掉进了
one of the many abandoned, unmarked mine shafts in the area. Some of these shafts were upwards of 100 years old. Over time, the soil surrounding the shaft openings had become unstable. If anyone stood too close, there was a genuine danger that the soil could fall in and cause the mine to collapse. A local prospector who had expert knowledge of the bell chambers area joined the constable and directed him to several of the mineshafts in the vicinity of the Kellerts campsite. At each one they shone a torch inside, but this only gave them visibility to around 10 metres deep. Some they could see all the way to the bottom, others they could not.
该地区许多废弃的、未标记的矿井中。其中一些矿井已有100多年的历史。随着时间的推移，矿井开口周围的土壤变得不稳定。如果有人站得太近，确实存在土壤塌陷并导致矿井坍塌的危险。一位对贝尔钱伯斯地区有专业知识的当地勘探者加入了警员的行列，并引导他前往凯莱特营地附近的几个矿井。在每一个矿井，他们都用手电筒往里照，但这只能让他们看到约10米深的地方。有些他们能一直看到底部，有些则不能。
They soon crossed paths with the other group who had been camping nearby. The group advised the constable to check out a mineshaft approximately 100 metres from where they'd been staying. Days earlier, they'd noticed a horrible odour emitting from within. days earlier, they'd noticed a horrible odour emitting from within. They'd assumed it to be a decaying kangaroo, but given the recent revelations, they weren't so sure. The mineshaft they were referring to was located atop a small mound roughly 1.8 kilometres north of the Kellett campsite and 1.2 kilometres north from the abandoned quad bike. It had two entrances which was common for the larger gold mines as it provided a second point of escape in the event that the mine collapsed. The two narrow openings were marked by worn
他们很快与附近露营的另一群人相遇。该小组建议警员检查距离他们居住地约100米处的一个矿井。几天前，他们注意到里面散发出一种可怕的恶臭。几天前，他们注意到里面散发出一种可怕的恶臭。他们以为是一只腐烂的袋鼠，但鉴于最近的发现，他们不太确定了。他们所指的矿井位于凯莱特营地以北约1.8公里、废弃四轮摩托车以北1.2公里处的一个小土丘顶上。它有两个入口，这在大型金矿中很常见，因为如果矿井坍塌，它提供了第二个逃生点。两个狭窄的开口由磨损的
timber frames. At around 1.5 metres wide they were just large enough for one person to enter at a time. When the constable and prospector arrived at the site, they could both smell the odour in question. The constable shone his torch down each of the mineshaft openings, but he couldn't see anything of note, nor did it smell like the Yoda was coming from within. He walked around the mound and found what he believed to be the source of the stench – a rotting kangaroo carcass. He passed this information on to his supervisor, who also came out to inspect the mineshaft,
木框架标记。它们宽约1.5米，刚好够一个人一次进入。当警员和勘探者到达现场时，他们都能闻到那种气味。警员用手电筒照向每个矿井开口，但他没看到任何值得注意的东西，气味也不像是从里面传出来的。他绕着土丘走了一圈，发现了被他认为是恶臭来源的东西——一具腐烂的袋鼠尸体。他将此信息传达给了他的主管，主管也出来检查了矿井，
and agreed the Yoda was coming from a dead animal. With no sign of Ray or Jenny by nightfall, a plane fitted with infrared thermal imaging cameras was deployed to scan the area overhead. If the couple were injured or missing in the wilderness, hopes were that the cameras could identify their body heat. It was unclear exactly how long Ray and Jenny had been missing, but the weather over the past few days had been favourable, with maximum temperatures of 31 degrees Celsius and a minimum of 12.5 degrees. There had also been significant rainfall, meaning they'd have had access to fresh water. Given that the Kelletts were experienced campers with no serious physical or mental health concerns, if they'd only gotten lost within the past few days,
并同意恶臭来自一只死动物。由于天黑时仍没有雷或珍妮的踪迹，一架装有红外热成像摄像机的飞机被部署到空中扫描该区域。如果这对夫妇在荒野中受伤或失踪，希望摄像机能识别出他们的体温。目前还不清楚雷和珍妮失踪了多久，但过去几天的天气一直很好，最高气温为31摄氏度，最低为12.5摄氏度。此外还有明显的降雨，这意味着他们应该能获得淡水。鉴于凯莱特夫妇是经验丰富的露营者，没有严重的身体或心理健康问题，如果他们只是在过去几天内迷路了，
then their chances of survival were considered to be relatively high. With no sign of the couple emerging overnight, a full land search operation kicked into gear the following morning. This was no easy task. The remote bell chambers area had no mobile phone reception and could only be accessed by four-wheel drive. Extra precautions had to be taken to ensure the safety of officers as they navigated their way around the old mineshafts. A total of 139 disused mines had been documented in the area, while it was also possible there were others that hadn't been recorded. Recent rainfall had made the ground waterlogged in places, which not only compromised the
那么他们的生存几率被认为相对较高。由于一夜过去仍没有这对夫妇的踪迹，第二天早上，全面的陆地搜寻行动启动了。这绝非易事。偏远的贝尔钱伯斯地区没有手机信号，只能通过四轮驱动车辆进入。必须采取额外的预防措施，以确保警员在绕过旧矿井时的人身安全。该地区记录了总共139个废弃矿井，同时也可能存在其他未被记录的矿井。最近的降雨使地面在某些地方变得泥泞不堪，这不仅损害了
integrity of the mineshafts, but had also wiped out any potential tracks that could provide a clue as to the Kellert's whereabouts. The initial foot search covered an area of 11 square kilometres. The tactical response team moved from mineshaft to mineshaft, throwing a luminescent stick inside each one to highlight the contents within. When no sign of Ray or Jenny was detected, the mine that had been checked was marked clear. Specially trained members of the State Emergency Service, as well as the Department of Fire and Emergency Services Urban Search and Rescue team also used their own equipment to look into each shaft. Both teams examined the mineshaft near
矿井的完整性，还抹去了任何可能提供凯莱特夫妇下落线索的潜在痕迹。最初的徒步搜寻覆盖了11平方公里的区域。战术响应小组从一个矿井移动到另一个矿井，向每个矿井内投掷一根荧光棒以照亮内部内容。当没有检测到雷或珍妮的迹象时，被检查过的矿井就被标记为“已清理”。受过专门训练的国家紧急服务成员，以及消防和紧急服务部门的城市搜救队也使用他们自己的设备检查了每个矿井。两支队伍都检查了凯莱特夫妇营地附近的
the Kellett's campsite where an unpleasant odour had been detected. The verdict was the same for each of them. Clear. them. Clear. When there was still no sign of Ray or Jenny by Friday April 3, Mounted Police began scouring the area on horseback. The Kellett's travelling companion, Graham Milne, was also brought in to assist with the search. He told the police that the trio had arrived at Bell Chambers on the afternoon of Thursday March 19, having each driven there in separate vehicles. Graham had been there on several prior prospecting trips, so he was already familiar with the area. They'd set up
矿井，那里曾检测到一种令人不快的气味。他们的结论是一样的。已清理。已清理。当到4月3日星期五仍没有雷或珍妮的踪迹时，骑警开始骑马搜寻该地区。凯莱特夫妇的同行伙伴格雷厄姆·米尔恩也被带过来协助搜寻。他告诉警方，三人于3月19日星期四下午抵达贝尔钱伯斯，每人分别驾驶车辆到达那里。格雷厄姆之前曾进行过几次勘探旅行，所以他已经熟悉了该地区。他们扎了
their camp a few kilometres from an area they'd collectively deemed the $3 million patch, as they hoped it might yield some valuable finds. Shortly after they began unpacking, Graham said that the Kellett's dog, Ella, became distracted by the wildlife and suddenly bolted off. He and Ray got on their quad bikes and took after her. Graham said it took them more than an hour to find her, after which they returned Ella to camp and continued exploring the area on their bikes. Jenny remained close to the camp as she didn't like to venture too far without someone being there to keep an eye on things.
营地，距离他们共同认为的“300万美元地块”几公里远，因为他们希望那里能有一些有价值的发现。在他们开始拆包后不久，格雷厄姆说凯莱特夫妇的狗埃拉被野生动物分散了注意力，突然跑开了。他和雷骑上四轮摩托车追了过去。格雷厄姆说他们花了一个多小时才找到她，之后他们把埃拉带回营地，并继续骑车探索该地区。珍妮一直待在营地附近，因为她不喜欢在没有人在场照看的情况下走得太远。
Their initial plan was to move their campsite closer to the $3 million patch. Graham and Ray went searching for a suitable route to drive their vehicles there, but the pathways were too narrow for Ray's new Land Rover, so they decided to stay put for the time being. The next morning, Graham said that he and Ray ventured off on the quad bikes again. It started to rain so they returned to camp while Jenny ventured to the nearby creek with a metal detector. Shortly after she returned, Graham claimed that Ella bolted again. He and Ray got on the quad bikes to chase after her for a second time, with Ray locating her after about 20 minutes. After returning Ella to camp, Graham said he and Ray spent the rest of the
他们最初的计划是将营地搬到离“300万美元地块”更近的地方。格雷厄姆和雷去寻找一条合适的路线来驾驶他们的车辆，但路径对雷的新路虎来说太窄了，所以他们决定暂时留在原地。第二天早上，格雷厄姆说他和雷再次骑着四轮摩托车出发了。天开始下雨，所以他们回到了营地，而珍妮带着金属探测器去了附近的溪流。在她回来后不久，格雷厄姆声称埃拉又跑了。他和雷骑上四轮摩托车第二次追赶她，雷在大约20分钟后找到了她。在把埃拉带回营地后，格雷厄姆说他和雷在摩托车上度过了剩下的
afternoon on the bikes before they all called it an early night. The next morning of Saturday March 21, Graham said they all got up at daybreak. According to Graham, after eating breakfast, Ella took off yet again. Fed up, Graham claims he told Ray and Jenny he came on the trip to go prospecting, not to constantly chase after their dog. He refused to help find her again, instead lending Jenny his quad bike so she could join Ray in the search. Graham said he told Jenny he was going to go prospecting on foot. He told Jenny to put his quad bike back in his trailer once she was done chasing Ella. Graham had to be back at work on March 24 and he planned on leaving first thing the following morning so that he'd have one day of rest before flying out to cloudbreak.
下午，然后他们都早早休息了。第二天早上，即3月21日星期六，格雷厄姆说他们都在天亮时起床了。据格雷厄姆说，吃完早餐后，埃拉又跑了。格雷厄姆声称他受够了，告诉雷和珍妮他是来勘探的，而不是为了不断追赶他们的狗。他拒绝再次帮忙寻找她，而是把他的四轮摩托车借给珍妮，这样她就可以加入雷的搜寻。格雷厄姆说他告诉珍妮他要徒步去勘探。他告诉珍妮在追完埃拉后把他的四轮摩托车放回他的拖车里。格雷厄姆必须在3月24日回到工作岗位，他计划第二天一早离开，这样他就能在飞往Cloudbreak之前休息一天。
Graham said that Ray and Jenny took off after Ella on the quad bikes while he headed off on his solo prospecting journey at around 6.30am. He stayed out all day and most of the night. When Graham eventually returned to the camp, he said it was dark and quiet. Graham didn't wear a watch, but he assumed the time to be between about 2 and 3am. Ella was there and he assumed Ray and Jenny were asleep. Graham said his quad bike was in his trailer just like he'd asked Jenny to leave it while Ray's quad bike was parked nearby. He spent about an hour quietly packing up his stuff before heading off. He said that Ray and Jenny knew he was leaving that night so there was no point waking them up to say goodbye. For the team leading the search for the Kellets, it was important to establish the last time that
格雷厄姆说雷和珍妮骑着四轮摩托车去追埃拉，而他在早上6点30分左右独自踏上了勘探之旅。他在外面待了一整天，大部分时间都在晚上。当格雷厄姆最终回到营地时，他说天已经黑了，很安静。格雷厄姆没戴手表，但他估计时间在凌晨2点到3点之间。埃拉在那里，他以为雷和珍妮睡着了。格雷厄姆说他的四轮摩托车在他的拖车里，就像他要求珍妮放的那样，而雷的四轮摩托车停在附近。他花了大约一个小时安静地收拾东西，然后出发了。他说雷和珍妮知道他那天晚上要走，所以没必要叫醒他们告别。对于领导搜寻凯莱特夫妇的团队来说，确定最后一次
Ray and Jenny had been seen alive. Based on Graham Milne's account, the last time he'd physically laid eyes on them was on the morning of Saturday March 21, before he set out on his solo prospecting trip. A few hours after Graham said he'd departed the camp on Sunday March 22, another pair of prospectors reported they'd driven past the Kellets camp. Ella had been there but Ray and Jenny had not, nor did they recall seeing Ray's red quad bike. A local farmer had been passing by the area later that evening when they saw Ella walking alone down the 200 kilometre dirt road connecting Sandstone to the town of Paynes Find. Two days later, on the afternoon of March 24, one Sandstone Council worker saw Ella out the Sandstone to Paynes Find road near the track to the Kellett's camp. Three days passed before another group passed through the remote area. On Friday March 27, the group recalled driving past the Kellett's campsite.
见到雷和珍妮还活着的时间非常重要。根据格雷厄姆·米尔恩的说法，他最后一次亲眼见到他们是在3月21日星期六早上，在他独自开始勘探之旅之前。在格雷厄姆说他于3月22日星期日离开营地几个小时后，另一对勘探者报告说他们开车经过了凯莱特夫妇的营地。埃拉在那里，但雷和珍妮不在，他们也不记得看到雷的红色四轮摩托车。那天晚上晚些时候，一位当地农民经过该地区时，看到埃拉独自走在连接桑德斯通到佩恩斯芬德镇的200公里土路上。两天后，即3月24日下午，一名桑德斯通议会工作人员看到埃拉在通往凯莱特营地的小路附近的桑德斯通至佩恩斯芬德路上。又过了三天，另一组人经过了这个偏远地区。3月27日星期五，该小组回忆说开车经过了凯莱特夫妇的营地。
Although they hadn't stopped, they recalled seeing Ella sitting on a blanket near one of the vehicles with no people inside. Ella was found wandering through the Sandstone Caravan Park the following day of Saturday March 28, where she remained for a couple of days before the alarm was officially raised on Tuesday March 31. This left a period of 10 days where there were no reported sightings of Ray or Jenny Kellett, meaning they could have gone missing anywhere within that timeframe. However, given that multiple people had seen Ella alone on and after March 22, it stood to reason that whatever had happened to Ray and Jenny had occurred sometime around that time. By all accounts, the Kelletts would not be without Ella without good reason.
虽然他们没有停下来，但他们记得看到埃拉坐在其中一辆车旁边的毯子上，里面没有人。第二天，即3月28日星期六，埃拉被发现独自在桑德斯通房车公园徘徊，她在那里待了几天，直到3月31日星期二正式发出警报。这留下了10天的时间，期间没有关于雷或珍妮·凯莱特的目击报告，这意味着他们可能在那段时间内的任何地方失踪。然而，鉴于多人在3月22日及之后看到埃拉独自一人，有理由认为雷和珍妮发生的任何事情都发生在那个时间左右。据各方说法，凯莱特夫妇没有正当理由是不会离开埃拉的。
Graham Milne revisited the campsite with the police and said it looked more or less the same as it did when he left on the 22nd. However, he said he'd left Ray and Jenny some prospecting equipment including a metal detector, a yellow GPS and a plastic gold pan, which were no longer at the campsite. Eager to get an understanding of Ray and Jenny's movements in the area, the police asked Graham to show them all the sites he visited with Ray. Graham jumped on his quad bike and directed them in a south-easterly direction. There was no sign of the couple at any point along the way. Police closed off the sandstone to Paynes Find Road while investigations continued, allowing Graham to camp alone
格雷厄姆·米尔恩与警方重访了营地，他说营地看起来和他22日离开时差不多。然而，他说他留给雷和珍妮一些勘探设备，包括一个金属探测器、一个黄色GPS和一个塑料淘金盘，这些东西在营地里已经不见了。为了了解雷和珍妮在该地区的活动，警方要求格雷厄姆带他们去他与雷一起访问过的所有地点。格雷厄姆跳上他的四轮摩托车，引导他们向东南方向前进。一路上没有任何这对夫妇的踪迹。警方封锁了桑德斯通至佩恩斯芬德公路，同时调查继续进行，允许格雷厄姆独自露营
just 100 metres from the Kellett's campsite. By Saturday April 4, the search for the couple reached its fifth fruitless day. If Ray and Jenny were lost in the wilderness or trapped in a mineshaft, their chances of survival at this point were deemed unlikely. With the pressure mounting, police began sorting through the couple's belongings for clues as to where they might have headed. In Jenny's backpack, they found something of interest. It was a hand-drawn map, known as a mud map. The map contained some GPS coordinates and a rough drawing of what appeared to be directions for how to get to the bell chambers camp from Sandstone.
距离凯莱特营地仅100米。到4月4日星期六，对这对夫妇的搜寻进入了第五个毫无结果的日子。如果雷和珍妮在荒野中迷路或被困在矿井中，此时他们的生存几率被认为很小。随着压力增大，警方开始整理这对夫妇的物品，寻找他们可能去向的线索。在珍妮的背包里，他们发现了一些有趣的东西。那是一张手绘地图，被称为“泥图”。地图上包含一些GPS坐标和一张粗略的图画，看起来像是从桑德斯通前往贝尔钱伯斯营地的路线指引。
From the camp, a black line led north to a single location marked only as First Hole. When presented with the mud map, Graham Milne said he and Ray had drawn it together while planning for their trip. Emails sent between him and Ray also made multiple references to an unspecified hole. But Graham claimed that they didn't end up camping at the location marked on the map because the ground was too hard and there was no grass for Ella. The first hole referred to what Graham called a crystal mine that he said Jenny was interested in. The existence of this map led police to wonder if Ray and Jenny had intended to abseil into one of the abandoned mineshafts. This was an uncommon practice,
从营地出发，一条黑线向北通往一个仅标记为“第一洞”的地点。当被出示这张泥图时，格雷厄姆·米尔恩说他和雷在计划旅行时一起画了它。他和雷之间发送的电子邮件也多次提到一个未指明的洞。但格雷厄姆声称他们最终没有在地图上标记的地点露营，因为地面太硬，而且没有埃拉吃的草。所谓的“第一洞”指的是格雷厄姆所说的水晶矿，他说珍妮对那个矿很感兴趣。这张地图的存在让警方怀疑雷和珍妮是否打算绳降进入其中一个废弃的矿井。这是一种不常见的做法，
given the high risk of the walls collapsing in, but it wasn't unheard of. The Kellets had previously told a friend of their plans to do so and they'd been practising abseiling at home. Graham Millen said he'd roped down into the shafts before, but claimed that the trio had no intention of doing so on this trip, nor did they bring the required gear. The final entry in Jenny's diary suggested otherwise. Written on March 18, the day before the trio departed for their trip, Jenny wrote, Hopefully go to Hole. Fingers crossed. Although police couldn't be sure exactly which hole this referred to, on Monday April 6 they shifted the focus of the search from the southward direction where Graham Milne had been leading them
考虑到墙壁坍塌的高风险，但这并非闻所未闻。凯莱特夫妇之前曾告诉一位朋友他们有这样的计划，并且他们一直在家里练习绳降。格雷厄姆·米尔恩说他以前曾用绳子下到矿井里，但声称三人在此次旅行中没有这样的打算，也没有携带所需的装备。珍妮日记中的最后一条记录表明情况并非如此。在三人出发旅行的前一天，即3月18日，珍妮写道：“希望去洞里。祈祷吧。”虽然警方无法确定这具体指的是哪个洞，但在4月6日星期一，他们将搜寻重点从格雷厄姆·米尔恩引导他们的南方方向转移到了
and north of the camp instead. While many of the mines north of the camp had already been given the all clear, this was based on a somewhat cursory inspection that didn't require the specialists to fully descend into each shaft. It was decided that they would return to the area to descend fully into the mine shafts so that they could inspect the very bottoms and rule each one out. The Kellett's disappearance had started gaining media attention and several members of the press gathered in the area to report on the current status of the search. Eager to get some relevant footage to accompany their news bulletin, one Channel 9 journalist requested to film one of the rope technicians as they lowered themselves into one of the old mineshafts. The police agreed and the task was assigned to Ashley Gasmere,
营地以北。虽然营地以北的许多矿井已经被宣布“已清理”，但这基于一种有些粗略的检查，并不要求专家完全下降到每个矿井底部。决定返回该区域完全下降到矿井底部，以便检查最底层并排除每一个矿井。凯莱特夫妇的失踪开始引起媒体关注，几名记者聚集在该地区报道搜寻的现状。为了获得一些相关镜头来配合他们的新闻简报，一名第9频道记者请求拍摄其中一名绳索技术员下降到旧矿井的过程。警方同意了，任务分配给了阿什利·加斯米尔，
a senior firefighter with the Department of Fire and Emergency Services Urban Search and Rescue team. Ashley and his team designated the closest mineshaft to their command post. It was the same shaft where the unpleasant odour had been detected around the time that Ray and Jenny were first reported missing. Given that it had already been given the all-clear by multiple search teams, Ashley intended to lower himself about three quarters of the way down for the media demonstration. He donned his helmet torch and began his descent into the 12 meter deep hole while a camera operator hovered above him. By the time he'd descended around 9 meters in, his eyes started to adjust to the darkness. That's when he saw something at the bottom.
他是消防和紧急服务部门城市搜救队的一名高级消防员。阿什利和他的团队指定了距离他们指挥所最近的矿井。这就是雷和珍妮刚被报告失踪时检测到令人不快气味的同一个矿井。鉴于它已经被多个搜寻小组宣布“已清理”，阿什利打算在媒体演示中下降到大约四分之三的位置。他戴上头盔灯，开始下降到12米深的洞中，而一名摄像师在他上方盘旋。当他下降到大约9米时，他的眼睛开始适应黑暗。就在那时，他在底部看到了东西。
Code 90, Code 90, Ashley shouted. A journalist standing at the top of the mine asked what the code meant. A firefighter standing nearby responded, that's a body. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. You know I love my meal kits. Being able to feast on a delicious meal without the long prep and cook times is what drew me to Home Chef over the other options. Home Chef's meals are effortless, even for someone like me who isn't making it on Top Chef anytime soon. Home Chef provides fresh ingredients and chef-designed recipes conveniently delivered to your doorstep to simplify your cooking experience. And they've got meal kits for every
“90号代码，90号代码，”阿什利大喊。站在矿井顶部的一名记者问这个代码是什么意思。附近的一名消防员回答说：“那是一具尸体。”Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。你知道我喜欢我的餐包。能够享用一顿美味的饭菜而无需漫长的准备和烹饪时间，这就是我选择Home Chef而不是其他选择的原因。Home Chef的餐点毫不费力，即使对于像我这样短期内不会成为顶级厨师的人来说也是如此。Home Chef提供新鲜食材和厨师设计的食谱，方便地送到您家门口，以简化您的烹饪体验。而且他们有适合每一种
kind of cook. There are classic meal kits with pre-portioned ingredients and easy instructions. Speedy recipes ready in less than 30 minutes. Oven ready kits with pre-chopped ingredients or quick microwave meals that assemble in minutes. Home Chef has you and the entire family covered for delicious meals without the hassle. Home Chef has over 30 options a week and serves a variety of dietary needs. They even have a delicious, kid-friendly family menu with 18 new options each week, which is picky eater approved and takes the stress out of dinnertime.
厨师的餐包。有配有预分量食材和简单说明的经典餐包。不到30分钟即可准备好的快速食谱。配有预切食材的烤箱即食套件，或几分钟内即可组装的快速微波炉餐点。Home Chef为您和全家人提供美味的餐点，无需麻烦。Home Chef每周有超过30种选择，满足各种饮食需求。他们甚至有美味的、适合儿童的家庭菜单，每周有18种新选择，这些选择通过了挑食者的认可，减轻了晚餐时间的压力。
Not only is Home Chef convenient, it's economical too. Their customers save an average of $86 per month on groceries. Olivia LaVoice, host of Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, is loving Home Chef for its convenience and the high quality of the ingredients supplied. She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made. For a limited time, Home Chef is offering our listeners 18 free meals plus free dessert for life and of course free shipping on your first box. Go to homechef.com slash casefile for 18 free meals and free dessert for life.
Home Chef不仅方便，而且经济。他们的客户平均每月在杂货上节省86美元。Casefile Presents系列《贝克斯菲尔德3》的主持人奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯非常喜欢Home Chef的便利性和所提供食材的高质量。她说这也向她介绍了她以前不会做的新食谱。在有限的时间内，Home Chef为我们的听众提供18份免费餐点，外加终身免费甜点，当然还有首个订单免费送货。前往homechef.com斜杠casefile获取18份免费餐点和终身免费甜点。
You heard that right. Homechef.com slash casefile. Must be an active subscriber to receive free dessert. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. The body at the bottom of the mineshaft was so decomposed that it was assumed to have been there for months or possibly even years. The level of decomposition meant an identification wasn't immediately possible, but given the amount of time the body had been there, it couldn't have
你没听错。Homechef.com斜杠casefile。必须是活跃订阅者才能获得免费甜点。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。矿井底部的尸体腐烂程度非常严重，以至于被认为已经在那里待了几个月甚至几年。腐烂程度意味着无法立即进行身份识别，但考虑到尸体在那里停留的时间，它不可能是
been Ray or Jenny Keller. The gathered search teams and members of the media were in awe that a random media stunt had led to the discovery of what was bound to be another long-term missing person. Word quickly spread throughout Sandstone, leading to immediate speculation among townsfolk and the gathered press, with one question on everyone's lips. What if a serial killer was on the loose in the outback town? However, those rumours came to a standstill when DNA testing later confirmed the identity of the body. It was Ray Kellett, after all. A team of forensic specialists was summoned to the area to begin the difficult task of retrieving Ray's remains. It took two days before they'd adequately assessed the site and determined it was only safe enough for one of them to enter the mineshaft.
雷或珍妮·凯莱特。聚集的搜寻小组和媒体成员感到敬畏，一个随机的媒体噱头竟然导致发现了另一个注定是长期失踪的人。消息迅速在桑德斯通传开，导致镇民和聚集的媒体之间立即产生猜测，每个人嘴边都有一个问题。如果内陆小镇上有一个连环杀手在逃怎么办？然而，当DNA检测后来确认了尸体的身份时，这些谣言平息了。毕竟，那是雷·凯莱特。法医专家小组被召集到该地区，开始回收雷遗骸的艰巨任务。他们花了整整两天时间才充分评估了现场，并确定只有其中一人进入矿井才是安全的。
While the shaft itself was approximately 1.5 meters wide, the base opened up into a bulb shaped space that was about 6 meters long, 3 meters wide and the base opened up into a bulb-shaped space that was about 6 meters long, 3 meters wide, and 2 and a half meters high. Directly below the opening was a conical-shaped mound made up of fallen debris and loose sandy material. Ray's body wasn't positioned centrally at the bottom of the hole, but off to the side and further back into the bulb-shaped section of the shaft. He lay face up, with his head closest to the shaft opening and his body further within. His legs were splayed out shoulder-width, his right arm was covered under loose rocks, and a large piece of old timber that had fallen from the collar of
虽然矿井本身宽约1.5米，但底部张开成一个球状空间，长约6米，宽3米，底部张开成一个球状空间，长约6米，宽3米，高2.5米。开口正下方是一个由坠落的碎片和松散沙质材料组成的圆锥形土堆。雷的尸体并没有位于洞底的中心，而是偏向一侧，更深入到矿井的球状部分。他仰面躺着，头部最靠近矿井开口，身体在更里面。他的双腿呈肩宽张开，右臂被松散的岩石覆盖，一块从矿井领口掉落的大块旧木头
the shaft lay on top of his right leg. He was wearing trousers and work boots with a pair of gloves in the pocket, but no shirt. Ray's remains were carefully extracted and removed for forensic analysis. An autopsy revealed he'd sustained a number of injuries to the upper half of his body, including broken bones to the left side of his neck and back, as well as a broken hyoid bone. There were also fractures to his left cheekbone and eye socket, and one of his left ribs was broken. His right hand had multiple fractures and three of his fingertip bones were missing. There were no injuries to the lower half of his body or to his teeth or jaw. Due to the level of decomposition, the pathologist was unable to determine how exactly
压在他的右腿上。他穿着裤子和工作靴，口袋里有一副手套，但没有穿衬衫。雷的遗骸被小心地提取出来并移走进行法医分析。尸检显示他上半身受了多处伤，包括左侧颈部和背部骨折，以及舌骨骨折。他的左颧骨和眼眶也有骨折，左侧一根肋骨断裂。他的右手有多处骨折，三个指尖骨头缺失。他下半身或牙齿、下颚没有受伤。由于腐烂程度，病理学家无法确定具体是如何
Ray Kellett had died or when the injuries occurred. All they could say for certain was that the injuries had been caused by blunt force trauma, possibly from the result of a fall. Significantly, there was no absaling equipment or prospecting gear at the bottom of the mineshaft to indicate that Ray had ventured into the hole willingly. But if he'd fallen into it by accident, then it raised several questions. The most obvious being, where was Jenny? When the families of Ray and Jenny heard the news that Ray's body had been identified, they were in a state of disbelief. Not only because of the news itself, but because they found out about it from a TV broadcast
雷·凯莱特（Ray Kellett）究竟是何时死亡的，或者受伤发生在何时，他们无法确定。他们唯一能肯定的是，这些伤是由钝器创伤造成的，可能是坠落的结果。值得注意的是，矿井底部没有任何绳降设备或探矿装备，这表明雷并非自愿进入洞中。但如果他是意外坠入，这就引出了几个问题。最明显的一个是：珍妮（Jenny）在哪里？当雷和珍妮的家人听到雷的遗体已被确认的消息时，他们感到难以置信。不仅是因为消息本身，还因为他们是从电视广播中得知这一消息的，
without so much as a call from the authorities. The wait for information had been excruciating, but the discovery of Ray's body didn't bring them any form of closure. It prompted more questions than it did answers. Based on the available evidence, investigators theorised that Ray and Jenny could have been hanging around at their campsite when Ella suddenly took off again. The couple could have immediately jumped on the back of Ray's quad bike which would explain why Ray had no shirt on and the campsite appeared to be abruptly abandoned. After chasing Ella on the quad bike, they might have jumped off to give
甚至没有接到当局的任何电话。等待消息的过程极其痛苦，但雷遗体的发现并没有给他们带来任何形式的了结。它引发的问题比答案更多。根据现有证据，调查人员推测，当埃拉（Ella）突然再次跑开时，雷和珍妮可能正在营地附近闲逛。这对夫妇可能立即跳上了雷的四轮摩托车后座，这就解释了为什么雷当时没穿上衣，而且营地看起来像是被匆忙遗弃的。在骑着四轮摩托车追赶埃拉之后，他们可能跳下车进行
chase on foot. Perhaps Ray chased Ella up the small mound surrounding the mineshaft and didn't see the opening until it was too late. Inconsolable at having witnessed him fall, Jenny might have stayed at the opening of the shaft in a state of shock and confusion, possibly waiting for Ray to regain consciousness. By the time night fell and she tried to make it back to either the campsite or the quad bike, she became disoriented and got lost in the process. Ray and Jenny's families didn't buy this theory for a second. For starters, they found Graham Milne's story about Ella running off to be incredibly odd. Ella was an elderly dog who followed Ray and Jenny everywhere they went, and she'd never been in the habit of running away.
徒步追赶。也许雷追着埃拉跑上了矿井周围的小土丘，直到为时已晚才看到那个洞口。珍妮目睹他坠落后悲痛欲绝，可能处于震惊和困惑中，一直待在井口，或许是在等待雷恢复意识。当夜幕降临，她试图返回营地或四轮摩托车处时，她迷失了方向，并在过程中走失了。雷和珍妮的家人一秒钟都不相信这个理论。首先，他们觉得格雷厄姆·米尔恩（Graham Milne）关于埃拉跑掉的故事非常奇怪。埃拉是一只老狗，无论雷和珍妮去哪儿，它都会跟着，而且它从来没有跑掉的习惯。
Ray and Jenny everywhere they went, and she'd never been in the habit of running away. In fact, she was so obedient that they barely ever had to tether her up. She was also a farm dog who was used to living around livestock and wildlife, and she'd never shown interest in chasing animals in the past. Ray's daughter Melanie had recently joined the Kellets on a camping and fishing trip and Ella had been impeccably behaved the whole time. She'd happily stayed at the campsite, untethered and unbothered by any of the passing wildlife. Besides, if Ella had been uncharacteristically running off, why hadn't they tethered her up?
雷和珍妮去哪儿，它都会跟着，而且它从来没有跑掉的习惯。事实上，它非常听话，他们几乎不需要把它拴起来。它也是一只农场犬，习惯了与牲畜和野生动物生活在一起，过去从未表现出追逐动物的兴趣。雷的女儿梅兰妮（Melanie）最近曾随凯莱特夫妇去露营和钓鱼，埃拉全程表现得无可挑剔。它愉快地待在营地里，没有被拴住，也没有被任何经过的野生动物打扰。此外，如果埃拉一反常态地跑开了，他们为什么没有把它拴起来？
Ray's family didn't think it was possible that Ray would have accidentally fallen down the mineshaft. Not only was the shaft opening clearly visible, Ray was an experienced outdoorsman who was incredibly safety conscious. Having been raised on a remote farming station only a few hundred kilometres away, he was acutely aware of the environmental hazards of the area. Even if Ray had been chasing Ella, he would have been keeping an eye out for any of the old mineshafts as he went. Furthermore, Ray never walked around topless, especially not when outdoors. He was the type to protect himself from the elements at all times, and was always fully clothed with a hat and sunglasses. Likewise, Jenny was also very experienced with the outdoors and considered by her daughters
雷的家人认为雷不可能意外掉进矿井。矿井口不仅清晰可见，而且雷是一位经验丰富的户外运动者，非常有安全意识。他在几百公里外的一个偏远农场站长大，对该地区的各种环境危险非常警觉。即使雷当时在追赶埃拉，他在行进过程中也会留意任何旧矿井。此外，雷从不赤裸上身走动，尤其是在户外时。他总是保护自己免受恶劣天气的影响，总是穿着整齐，戴着帽子和太阳镜。同样，珍妮在户外也非常有经验，被她的女儿们
to be tough as nails. On the off chance that Ray really did fall down the mineshaft, her family didn't think she would have gotten lost finding their camp. The pathways back were too obvious. And if she had become lost while looking for her way back, it didn't explain why she hadn't been found during the extensive search operation. Ray's post-mortem examination supported another possibility entirely. While it was possible that he'd fallen face first down the mineshaft, hitting his body on the walls on his way down, pathologists concluded it was also possible that Ray's injuries had been caused by a weapon during a physical assault.
认为是坚强如铁。万一雷真的掉进了矿井，她的家人认为她也不会在找回营地的路上迷路。回来的路径太明显了。如果她在寻找回程路时迷路了，那也无法解释为什么在广泛的搜救行动中没有找到她。雷的尸检结果完全支持了另一种可能性。虽然他有可能脸朝下掉进矿井，在下坠过程中身体撞击井壁，但病理学家得出结论，雷的伤也可能是身体受到攻击时被武器造成的。
The damage to his right hand was considered a high-violence injury, the kind more commonly seen in motorcycle accidents. Perhaps Ray put his hand out to protect himself from an attack. A drop of his own blood was found on the top of his left boot. Forensic experts determined this could have only fallen there while Ray was standing upright, potentially from a head injury. Blood had also seeped deep into the grooves on the soles of his boots, indicating that Ray had been standing in a pool of his own blood before becoming incapacitated. A red petrol can lay approximately three metres from Ray's body, further into the bulbous end of
他右手受到的损伤被认为是一种高暴力伤害，这种伤害在摩托车事故中更为常见。也许雷伸出手来保护自己免受攻击。在他的左靴顶部发现了一滴他自己的血。法医专家确定，这滴血只能是在雷站立时滴落的，可能来自头部受伤。血液也渗入了靴底的凹槽深处，这表明雷在失去知觉之前曾站在自己的一滩血泊中。一个红色的汽油桶躺在距离雷的遗体约三米处，更深入到
the mineshaft. That too was spattered with Ray's blood, but there was no other evidence of blood spatter anywhere else in the mineshaft, including on a plastic pump brand water bottle that was found lying between Ray's legs. Testing of the bottle's spout revealed DNA belonging to Ray, Jenny, and Graham Milne, which was consistent with Graham's story that the three shared communal water bottles. To Ashley Gasmere, the senior firefighter who had found Ray's body, the position that Ray was found lying in was unusual. In Ashley's experience, someone being face-up with their legs splayed could be indicative of having been dragged there. There were no drag marks at the site to confirm this, but given the amount of time that had passed
矿井的球状末端。那个桶上也溅有雷的血迹，但矿井的其他任何地方都没有其他血迹喷溅的证据，包括在雷双腿之间发现的一个塑料泵牌水瓶。对瓶嘴的检测显示，上面有属于雷、珍妮和格雷厄姆·米尔恩的DNA，这与格雷厄姆关于三人共用水瓶的说法一致。对于发现雷遗体的资深消防员阿什利·加斯米尔（Ashley Gasmere）来说，雷被发现时的姿势很不寻常。根据阿什利的经验，一个人脸朝上、双腿张开的姿势可能表明他曾被拖拽到那里。现场没有拖拽痕迹可以证实这一点，但考虑到已经过去的时间，
before the body was found, coupled with the recent rainfall, it couldn't be ruled out. The break in Ray's hyoid bone also raised some questions. This U-shaped bone sits at the root of the tongue and serves as a structural anchor in the neck. Breaks to the hyoid bone can be caused by falls from a great height, motor vehicle accidents or blunt force trauma, but most commonly, this injury is caused by strangulation or hanging. Graham Millne claimed the trio had never visited the mineshaft where Ray's body was found. The location of the mine was compared to the mud map Graham had drawn that was found in Jenny's luggage.
加上最近的降雨，这一点不能被排除。雷舌骨的断裂也引发了一些问题。这块U形骨头位于舌根，在颈部起到结构锚定的作用。舌骨断裂可能是由高处坠落、机动车事故或钝器创伤引起的，但最常见的是由勒死或吊死引起的。格雷厄姆·米尔恩声称，三人从未去过发现雷遗体的那个矿井。矿井的位置被拿来与格雷厄姆绘制并发现于珍妮行李中的泥图进行了对比。
It was remarkably close to the site designated First Hole. With all these details, the question loomed. Had Ray fallen down the hole by accident or had someone accompanied him to the bottom and launched an attack? In light of these forensic details, a press conference was held. A detective working on the case said they had not yet drawn any conclusions about what had happened to Ray and Jenny Kellett, but quote, At this point in time, we're not seeing anything that suggests criminality. Channel 9 journalist Liam Bartlett was in the crowd and couldn't believe what he was hearing. Are you
它与标为“第一洞”（First Hole）的地点非常接近。有了所有这些细节，问题就浮现了。雷是意外掉进洞里的，还是有人陪他到底部并对他发动了攻击？鉴于这些法医细节，警方举行了新闻发布会。一名负责此案的侦探表示，他们尚未就雷和珍妮·凯莱特发生了什么得出任何结论，但引用原话：“目前，我们没有看到任何暗示犯罪的迹象。”第九频道的记者利亚姆·巴特利特（Liam Bartlett）当时在人群中，简直不敢相信自己的耳朵。你
serious? He asked. There's nothing suspicious about this. The detective responded, At this point in time we're saying there is no evidence of any criminality. However, we are making sure we investigate it thoroughly and look at all the possibilities. The families of Ray and Jenny were just as shocked. Not only did the forensic evidence arouse suspicion, there was also the issue of the two guns that were found in the unlocked passenger seat of Ray's car, one of which was loaded. Ray had spent his whole life around firearms and was fastidious about gun safety. He only ever put bullets in his rifle when he was about to shoot. For Ray's family, there was no way he would have left a loaded firearm in an unlocked vehicle,
是认真的吗？他问道。这没有什么可疑的吗？侦探回答说：“目前我们说没有犯罪证据。然而，我们正在确保彻底调查，并审视所有可能性。”雷和珍妮的家人同样感到震惊。不仅法医证据引起了怀疑，雷车内未上锁的副驾驶座上发现的两把枪也是一个问题，其中一把还是上膛的。雷一生都与枪支打交道，对枪支安全非常谨慎。他只有在准备射击时才会往步枪里装子弹。对雷的家人来说，他绝不可能把一把上膛的枪留在未上锁的车里，
not even if he'd been cleaning it and had to leave the camp urgently. Two rounds were also missing from the unsecured rifle, leading some to wonder whether this could have been used in an attack against Ray and Jenny. Ray's autopsy had revealed that a three millimetre portion of his cheekbone had become dislodged. Given the blood on his boots, this injury could have been the result of a gunshot wound. But when later questioned, Graham Milne had an explanation for the two missing rounds. He said that shortly after the trio arrived at Bell Chambers on Thursday March 19, he and Ray were out on their quad bikes when they heard gunshots.
即使他在清理枪支时必须紧急离开营地也不可能。那把未上锁的步枪里还少了两发子弹，这让一些人怀疑这是否被用于对雷和珍妮的攻击。雷的尸检显示，他颧骨上有一块三毫米的部分脱落了。考虑到他靴子上的血迹，这种伤害可能是枪伤的结果。但当后来被问及时，格雷厄姆·米尔恩对缺失的两发子弹有一个解释。他说，在三人于3月19日星期四抵达贝尔钱伯斯（Bell Chambers）后不久，他和雷骑着四轮摩托车外出时听到了枪声。
They went up to higher ground to get a better view of the area and saw there was another vehicle approximately 500 metres in the distance. It was a white Toyota four-wheel drive with two men inside. Graham said they wanted to let the other men know of their presence in the area, so he placed an empty cigarette pack in a tree and told Ray to aim at it with his rifle. Ray took one shot, which missed, and then another one, which hit the target right in the centre. Based on this description, police released a statement urging the occupants of a white Toyota four-wheel drive who had been in the area at the time to come forward. Nobody did.
他们走到高处以获得更好的视野，看到大约500米外有另一辆车。那是一辆白色的丰田四驱车，里面有两名男子。格雷厄姆说，他们想让那两个人知道他们在该地区，所以他把一个空烟盒放在树上，告诉雷用步枪瞄准它。雷开了一枪，没打中，然后又开了一枪，正中目标中心。根据这一描述，警方发布了一份声明，敦促当时在该地区的白色丰田四驱车的乘员主动联系。没有人这样做。
Meanwhile, the search for Jenny Kellett resumed under the assumption that she too was deceased. Specially trained officers spent a week fully descending into 160 mineshafts in the area and declaring them all to be clear. The mineshaft where Ray's body had been found was also thoroughly inspected for any clues as to Jenny's whereabouts. While the officers found no evidence to suggest that Jenny had ever been down there, they did find something of interest on the surface. Approximately three metres from the mineshaft opening were three cigarette butts, all lying within 30 centimetres of one another. Police had actually noticed the butts there one month earlier upon the retrieval of Ray's remains, but hadn't thought to seize them because the area wasn't being considered a crime scene.
与此同时，对珍妮·凯莱特的搜寻在假设她也已死亡的情况下恢复了。受过专门训练的警官花了一周时间，彻底下到了该地区的160个矿井中，并宣布它们全部排查完毕。发现雷遗体的矿井也经过了彻底检查，以寻找关于珍妮下落的任何线索。虽然警官们没有发现任何证据表明珍妮曾去过那里，但他们在地面上发现了一些有趣的东西。距离矿井口约三米处有三个烟头，都躺在彼此30厘米的范围内。警方实际上在一个月前回收雷的遗体时就注意到了那里的烟头，但没想过要扣押它们，因为该地区当时并未被视为犯罪现场。
This time, they bagged the butts and sent them away for forensic testing, along with the remnants of a small fire that was also found nearby. The ashes from the fire revealed nothing of interest, but the cigarette butts did. Jenny Kellett was a smoker and two of the butts tested positive for her DNA. This indicated that Jenny had stood near the opening of the mine at some point during the camping trip. It also added weight to the theory that she could have witnessed Ray fall into the hole and had stood at the top in a state of distress before becoming disoriented and getting lost on her way back to the can. The third part also tested positive for DNA, but it wasn't Jenny's. It was Graham Milne's.
这一次，他们把烟头装进袋子送去进行法医鉴定，同时送检的还有附近发现的一个小火堆的残余物。火堆的灰烬没有发现任何有价值的东西，但烟头却有。珍妮·凯莱特是一名吸烟者，其中两个烟头检测出她的DNA呈阳性。这表明珍妮在露营期间的某个时候曾站在矿井口附近。这也增加了这样一种理论的权重：她可能目睹了雷掉进洞里，并在极度痛苦中站在洞口，随后在返回营地的路上迷失了方向。第三个烟头也检测出DNA阳性，但不是珍妮的。那是格雷厄姆·米尔恩的。
Ray and Jenny's belongings had already been handed back to their families and the police had previously turned down an offer from Jenny's family to forensically examine her things. With the discovery of the cigarette butts, their belongings were formally examined for the first time. A pillow case found in the Kellett's tent revealed two DNA profiles. Jenny Kellett's and Graham Milne's. Ray's DNA was not present. Based on these findings, police considered whether Jenny and Graham could have been having an affair. Jenny's loved ones strongly shut this down. Not only did Jenny and Ray have an incredibly happy and loving marriage,
雷和珍妮的财物已经交还给了他们的家人，警方此前曾拒绝了珍妮家人提出的对她的物品进行法医检查的提议。随着烟头的发现，他们的财物首次被正式检查。在凯莱特夫妇的帐篷里发现的一个枕套上显示出两个DNA图谱：珍妮·凯莱特和格雷厄姆·米尔恩的。雷的DNA不在其中。基于这些发现，警方考虑了珍妮和格雷厄姆是否可能有过婚外情。珍妮的亲人强烈否认了这一点。珍妮和雷不仅拥有极其幸福和恩爱的婚姻，
Graham Milne was not the type of person Jenny would have a romantic interest in. The two had met while working at the Cloudbreak mining site. Graham was a paramedic and he treated Jenny when she was experiencing back pain during which Ray had accompanied her to her appointments. The three of them began sitting together during work meals and Graham began teaching the Kellets more about prospecting for gold. He'd visited their farm on a few occasions but only in the context of teaching them practical prospecting skills such as how to use a metal detector and adequately prepare their vehicles for a trip. Ray and Jenny's children recalled that during these visits, when they weren't working on prospecting related things, Graham Milne mostly kept to himself. They found him to be a bit
格雷厄姆·米尔恩也不是珍妮会产生浪漫兴趣的那种人。两人是在云破（Cloudbreak）矿区工作时认识的。格雷厄姆是一名护理人员，在珍妮背痛时为她治疗，期间雷曾陪她去就诊。三人开始在工作餐时坐在一起，格雷厄姆开始教凯莱特夫妇更多关于淘金的知识。他曾几次访问他们的农场，但仅限于教他们实用的探矿技能，例如如何使用金属探测器以及如何为旅行充分准备车辆。雷和珍妮的孩子们回忆说，在这些访问期间，当他们不忙于探矿相关的事情时，格雷厄姆·米尔恩大多独处。他们觉得他有点
socially awkward and he didn't contribute much to conversations. Jenny was the type of person who wanted everyone to feel welcome. If anything, her children thought Graham might have developed unreciprocated feelings for Jenny because she'd made him feel special. When questioned by the police, Graham Milne denied ever having a romantic relationship with Jenny. He explained that the pillow containing both of their DNA was actually his. He'd lent it to Jenny on the drive up to Sandstone to help relieve her bad back. Graham's de facto partner confirmed the pillow was theirs. As for the cigarette butts, Graham Milne said he'd never left the campsite with the Jenny.
社交笨拙，在谈话中贡献不多。珍妮是一个希望每个人都感到受欢迎的人。如果说有什么的话，她的孩子们认为格雷厄姆可能对珍妮产生了单相思，因为她让他感到自己很特别。当被警方询问时，格雷厄姆·米尔恩否认与珍妮有过任何浪漫关系。他解释说，那个包含两人DNA的枕头实际上是他的。他在开车去桑德斯通（Sandstone）的路上把它借给珍妮，以帮助缓解她严重的背痛。格雷厄姆的事实伴侣证实了枕头是他们的。至于烟头，格雷厄姆·米尔恩说他从未和珍妮一起离开过营地。
He said he typically threw his cigarette butts in the bin unless they were out in the wilderness, in which case he flicked them into the distance. Graham claimed he'd never gone anywhere near the mineshaft where Ray's body was found and could therefore think of no reason why a cigarette butt with his DNA on it was found nearby. By mid-July, almost four months had passed with no sign of Jenny Kellett. Her bank accounts remained untouched, she'd made no attempts to contact her family, and nobody had come forward with any leads. Although it was presumed that Jenny was no longer alive, finding her remains was paramount. Not only to provide closure to her loved ones, but also to provide further insight into what
他说他通常把烟头扔进垃圾桶，除非是在荒野中，那种情况下他会把烟头弹到远处。格雷厄姆声称他从未去过发现雷遗体的矿井附近，因此想不出为什么附近会发现一个带有他DNA的烟头。到7月中旬，近四个月过去了，珍妮·凯莱特依然杳无音讯。她的银行账户未被动用，她没有尝试联系家人，也没有人提供任何线索。虽然推测珍妮已经不在人世，但找到她的遗体至关重要。不仅是为了给她的亲人一个了结，也是为了进一步深入了解
happened to the Kellets during their fateful camping trip. The search for Jenny expanded further south. After a week with no breakthroughs, it was called off for good. The case came to national attention when it was subsequently featured on an episode of the Channel 7 current affairs program, Sunday Night. Graham Milne appeared on the segment, during which he addressed allegations that he knew more about the Kellett's disappearance than he was letting on. I can't stop people drawing their own conclusions, Graham said. You're gonna get that. It doesn't matter what. People are gonna say things. Well, they can keep saying them, it doesn't matter. They don't know."
凯莱特夫妇在他们那次宿命般的露营旅行中发生了什么。对珍妮的搜寻向南进一步扩大。在一周没有取得突破后，搜寻工作被彻底取消。当此案随后在第七频道时事节目《周日之夜》（Sunday Night）的一集中播出时，引起了全国的关注。格雷厄姆·米尔恩出现在该节目中，他在节目中回应了关于他知道更多关于凯莱特夫妇失踪内情却隐瞒不报的指控。“我无法阻止人们得出自己的结论，”格雷厄姆说。“你会遇到这种情况。无论如何，人们都会说三道四。好吧，他们可以继续说，没关系。他们什么都不知道。”
When asked what he thought happened to Ray and Jenny, Graham became visibly upset. With tears running down his face, he said, "'I don't know. I've run through all sorts of different scenarios and nothing makes sense. Nothing makes sense at all. If anybody knows anything, please come forward and tell the police." Perth couple Georgina Granville and her husband Mark were watching Sunday night when they were immediately taken back to the morning of Sunday March 22, 2015. At around 5.30am the Granvilles had been driving south from Sandstone down the 200km long remote unsealed dirt road known as the Paynes Find to Sandstone Road.
当被问及他认为雷和珍妮发生了什么时，格雷厄姆明显变得不安。泪水顺着他的脸流下来，他说：“我不知道。我脑海中闪过各种不同的场景，但没有一个说得通。根本没有任何逻辑。如果有人知道什么，请站出来告诉警方。”珀斯夫妇乔治娜·格兰维尔（Georgina Granville）和她的丈夫马克（Mark）正在观看《周日之夜》，他们立刻回到了2015年3月22日星期日的那天早上。大约凌晨5点30分，格兰维尔夫妇正开车从桑德斯通向南行驶，沿着那条200公里长的偏远未铺设土路，即佩恩斯发现路（Paynes Find to Sandstone Road）。
They were about 25km from the Sandstone turn-off when, through the darkness, they saw the lights of a vehicle parked on the side of the road up ahead. As they got closer, they saw that it was a dark-coloured four-wheel drive with a trailer containing a quad bike attached to it. An older man was standing outside of the vehicle, sorting through a toolbox. Thinking he might need help, the Granvilles slowed down. Instead of acknowledging their concern, the man aggressively waved them off, as though to say, go away, shoo. When the Granvilles later learned about the disappearance of Ray and Jenny Kellett,
他们距离桑德斯通岔路口约25公里，在黑暗中，他们看到了前方路边停着一辆车的灯光。当他们靠近时，看到那是一辆深色的四驱车，后面拖着一个装有四轮摩托车的拖车。一名年长的男子站在车外，正在整理工具箱。格兰维尔夫妇以为他可能需要帮助，便减慢了车速。那名男子没有理会他们的关心，而是粗暴地挥手让他们走开，好像在说：“走开，去去去。”当格兰维尔夫妇后来得知雷和珍妮·凯莱特失踪的消息时，
they called Crimestoppers to report this sighting. They never heard anything back, so they assumed it mustn't have been of any interest. Watching the segment featuring Graham Milne on Sunday night, Georgina turned to her husband and said, Sunday night, Georgina turned to her husband and said, The man we saw on the side of the road. That's him. When presented with the information this time around, the police took an immediate interest. There were only two ways to get from the Bell Chambers campsite and back on the road to Perth. You could either travel the 30 kilometres north back to Sandstone and take the Bitumen Highway to Mount Magnet,
他们打电话给灭罪热线（Crimestoppers）报告了这次目击事件。他们从未收到任何回音，所以他们认为这一定没什么意义。在《周日之夜》节目中看到格雷厄姆·米尔恩的片段时，乔治娜转向她的丈夫说：“我们在路边看到的那个男人。就是他。”这一次，当信息被提交时，警方立即产生了兴趣。从贝尔钱伯斯营地回到通往珀斯的路上只有两条路。你可以向北行驶30公里回到桑德斯通，然后走沥青公路前往芒特马格内特（Mount Magnet），
which was a smoother ride but added around an extra 100 kilometres to your journey. Alternatively, you could head south on the Paynes Find to Sandstone Road, which was technically a shortcut, but it meant you had to take the unsealed dirt road. Graham Milne had told the police that when he departed the campsite between 2 or 3am on Sunday March 22, he took the bitumen highway because he'd been having car trouble and didn't want to risk taking the unsealed road. There was also less chance of hitting a kangaroo on the highway. He claimed he had a brief rest stop along the way but otherwise headed straight home to Perth. But if the witness sighting reported by the
那条路更平坦，但行程增加了约100公里。或者，你可以沿着佩恩斯发现路向南行驶，这在技术上是一条捷径，但意味着你必须走未铺设的土路。格雷厄姆·米尔恩曾告诉警方，当他在3月22日星期日凌晨2点到3点之间离开营地时，他走了沥青公路，因为他的车出了点毛病，不想冒险走土路。而且在公路上撞到袋鼠的可能性也较小。他声称他在途中短暂休息了一下，但除此之外就直接开车回珀斯了。但如果格兰维尔夫妇报告的目击事件是正确的，
Granvilles was correct, this led to the question of why Graham Milne would lie about the route he took home. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. listening to this episode's sponsors. Had Graham Milne travelled home via Mount Magnet as he described, the journey would have required him to pause at a stop sign outside of a BP service station before turning left onto the highway. To verify Milne's version of events, police obtained CCTV footage from the BP recorded on the morning of Sunday March 22. At no point did Graham Millan's vehicle drive past.
这就引出了一个问题：为什么格雷厄姆·米尔恩要撒谎说他回家的路线？Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。如果格雷厄姆·米尔恩像他描述的那样经由芒特马格内特回家，这段旅程将要求他在左转进入公路前，在BP加油站外的一个停车标志处暂停。为了核实米尔恩的说法，警方获取了BP加油站3月22日星期日早上录制的闭路电视录像。格雷厄姆·米尔恩的车从未经过那里。
Millan's car was fitted with a GPS tracking device. With suspicions raised, police downloaded his GPS data from March 22 and found there was no record of his movements in those early hours of Sunday morning. This in and of itself wasn't particularly noteworthy. The GPS was reliant on satellite connection which might have been difficult to establish given the remoteness of the area. Milne also claimed that the GPS was faulty and prone to overheating. However, at 10.17am the connection kicked in. At a time Milne claimed to be on the highway, well on his way back to Perth, the GPS data showed his car was actually travelling south down the unsealed road, just outside of Paynes Find, approximately 206 kilometres from the Kelletts campsite.
米尔恩的车上装有GPS追踪装置。随着怀疑加深，警方下载了他3月22日的GPS数据，发现没有他在那个星期日凌晨活动的记录。这本身并不特别值得注意。GPS依赖于卫星连接，考虑到该地区的偏远程度，建立连接可能很困难。米尔恩还声称GPS有故障，容易过热。然而，在上午10点17分，连接接通了。在米尔恩声称自己在公路上、已经在回珀斯路上的时间里，GPS数据显示他的车实际上正沿着土路向南行驶，就在佩恩斯发现路外，距离凯莱特夫妇的营地约206公里。
If the sighting reported by the Granfills was correct, this meant he'd remained in the area for approximately five hours after they drove by. On Tuesday November 3, 2015, seven months after Ray's body was found, Graham Milne was officially taken into police custody for questioning. When presented with the conflicting GPS data, he didn't deny it. Instead, he claimed he'd told the police the wrong thing when first questioned. According to Milne, what really happened was he started heading down the highway towards Mount Magnet, but when he reached the Paynes Find to Sandstone Road turnoff,
如果格兰维尔夫妇报告的目击事件是正确的，这意味着他在他们开车经过后又在该地区停留了大约五个小时。2015年11月3日星期二，在发现雷的遗体七个月后，格雷厄姆·米尔恩被正式带入警局接受讯问。当被出示相互矛盾的GPS数据时，他没有否认。相反，他声称自己在第一次被讯问时说错了话。据米尔恩说，真正发生的事情是他开始沿着公路向芒特马格内特行驶，但当他到达佩恩斯发现路到桑德斯通路的岔路口时，
he had a sudden change of mind. He decided he wanted to go back and continue prospecting with the Kellets after all. Milne explained that his car was running well by that point, so he started heading along the unsealed road back towards Bell Chambers. But after about 15 minutes, he changed his mind again. Milne said he had to be back at work and he knew that if he'd carried on, the rest of his crew would have been short-staffed. Instead, he turned around again and headed back towards Perth. The police asked Mjoln why he didn't tell them about this the first time around. He said he'd been too embarrassed and didn't want to look like an idiot. Regardless, this still didn't explain why his car was in the
他突然改变了主意。他决定还是想回去和凯莱特夫妇继续探矿。米尔恩解释说，他的车当时运行良好，所以他开始沿着土路向贝尔钱伯斯方向行驶。但在大约15分钟后，他又改变了主意。米尔恩说他必须回去工作，他知道如果他继续走，他的其余船员就会人手不足。相反，他又调头向珀斯方向驶去。警方问米尔恩为什么第一次没告诉他们这些。他说他当时太尴尬了，不想看起来像个白痴。无论如何，这仍然无法解释为什么他的车在
area some seven hours after he claimed to have left the campsite. When it was revealed that CCTV footage hadn't captured his car passing through Mount Magnet, Milne explained he must have taken the dirt road behind the BP station. There was indeed a dirt road that looped behind the BP, but it made no sense that Milne would have taken this route. It wasn't a shortcut, and being a dirt road, it would have only added extra difficulty to his journey given he was trailing his quad bike behind. With so many inconsistencies, police were starting to have doubts about Graham Millen's version of events. A search warrant was executed at Millen's house and various electronics were seized. Police found no significant information on his phone, but a co-worker came forward with
他声称离开营地约七小时后还在该地区。当闭路电视录像显示没有拍到他的车经过芒特马格内特时，米尔恩解释说他一定走了BP加油站后面的土路。BP后面确实有一条土路，但米尔恩走这条路毫无意义。它不是捷径，而且作为一条土路，考虑到他后面拖着四轮摩托车，这只会增加他旅程的难度。由于存在如此多的不一致之处，警方开始对格雷厄姆·米尔恩的说法产生怀疑。警方对米尔恩的家执行了搜查令，并扣押了各种电子设备。警方在他的手机上没有发现任何重要信息，但一名同事提出了一个
an eyebrow-raising claim. According to them, on Milne's first shift back at work after the prospecting trip with the Kellets, Milne asked for help to wipe his phone clean. Milne claimed he was giving the phone to a relative, yet he never did. The coworker helped clear the phone, but didn't see anything of note during the process. Police were also increasingly curious about the supposed overnight prospecting venture Milne claimed to have gone on on Saturday March 21. He claimed that he'd set out on the journey at around 6.30am and then returned to the campsite at around 2am. All of this was on foot and with limited supplies. Prospecting at night wasn't an
令人惊讶的说法。据他们说，在米尔恩与凯莱特夫妇探矿旅行后回到工作岗位的第一班，米尔恩请求帮助清除手机里的内容。米尔恩声称他要把手机给亲戚，但他从未这样做过。同事帮忙清除了手机，但在过程中没有看到任何值得注意的东西。警方也越来越好奇米尔恩声称在3月21日星期六进行的所谓通宵探矿冒险。他声称他在早上6点30分左右出发，然后在凌晨2点左右回到营地。所有这些都是徒步进行的，且补给有限。夜间探矿并不是一个
entirely unusual practice. As Milne explained, gold can shimmer in the dark under torchlight. But as local prospectors have pointed out, it would be near impossible to make any such discoveries in 2015, as any gold on the surface had been detected by equipment decades earlier. Furthermore, the trip seemed unusually long, especially without at least stopping back at camp to renew his water supply or get something to eat. Inquiries were made with other individuals who had prospected for gold with Graham Milne in the past. An ex-workmate had joined him on several prospecting trips and recalled the longest they'd ever
完全不寻常的做法。正如米尔恩解释的那样，黄金在手电筒光下可能会在黑暗中闪烁。但正如当地探矿者指出的那样，在2015年几乎不可能有任何此类发现，因为地表的任何黄金几十年前就已经被设备探测过了。此外，这次旅行看起来异常漫长，尤其是在没有至少回营地补充水源或吃点东西的情况下。警方询问了过去曾与格雷厄姆·米尔恩一起探矿的其他个人。一位前同事曾多次参加他的探矿旅行，并回忆说他们曾经
spent out prospecting was around four hours at a time. He also claimed that during these trips, Milne often tied a rope to his quad bike and used it to abseil down old mineshafts. If Milne's account that he prospected for approximately 18 hours straight was correct, this also raised the question of why he would then begin a long-distance drive without stopping to rest first. The 7 hour drive back to Perth would have been a gruelling stint for someone who hadn't slept in almost 24 hours.
在外面探矿最长的时间大约是每次四个小时。他还声称，在这些旅行中，米尔恩经常把绳子系在四轮摩托车上，并用它从旧矿井中绳降。如果米尔恩声称他连续探矿约18小时的说法是正确的，这也引出了一个问题：为什么他随后会开始长途驾驶而不先停下来休息。对于一个近24小时没睡觉的人来说，回珀斯的7小时车程将是一段极其艰苦的经历。
Even more so considering Milne's journey home had actually taken almost double that time, with the GPS data recording him arriving home at 8.17pm. The ex-workmate of Milne's who had prospected with him in the past also said that Milne would only have a drive in the daytime. The search of Graham Milne's home turned up nothing that implicated him in Ray's death or Jenny's disappearance or suggested a motive. After being held in custody overnight and questioned for 12 hours, Milne was free to go. Yet police remained curious about the GPS coordinates that placed Milne on the Paynes Find to Sandstone Road at around 10am on Sunday March 22.
考虑到米尔恩回家的旅程实际上花费了几乎两倍的时间，GPS数据显示他在晚上8点17分才到家，这就更令人怀疑了。那位过去曾与米尔恩一起探矿的前同事还说，米尔恩只会在白天开车。对格雷厄姆·米尔恩家的搜查没有发现任何牵连他导致雷死亡或珍妮失踪的证据，也没有暗示任何动机。在被拘留过夜并接受了12小时讯问后，米尔恩获释。然而，警方仍然对在3月22日星期日早上10点左右将米尔恩定位在佩恩斯发现路到桑德斯通路的GPS坐标感到好奇。
A team was dispatched to search the area where the GPS had pinged, but nothing of interest was found. After what had seemed like a potential breakthrough, the investigation hit another dead end. Months passed with no new information coming to light. By October 2017, two and a half years passed since the Kellets set out on their fateful prospecting trip. With the case now being treated as a potential homicide, the Western Australian Police announced a $250,000 reward was available for anyone with information that led to a conviction. The Police Commissioner stated, Sandstone is a very small community. It's subject to a lot of mining exploration and people who
一个小组被派往搜索GPS定位的区域，但没有发现任何有价值的东西。在经历了看似潜在的突破后，调查陷入了另一个死胡同。几个月过去了，没有新的信息浮出水面。到2017年10月，距离凯莱特夫妇踏上那次宿命般的探矿之旅已经过去了两年半。由于此案现在被视为潜在的谋杀案，西澳大利亚警方宣布，为任何提供导致定罪信息的人提供25万澳元的奖励。警察局长表示：“桑德斯通是一个非常小的社区。它受到很多矿产勘探的影响，人们可能会
might camp or move through the area on holidays. It's about the most remote area you could find on the planet. There's not many people who would have been in that area at the time. Someone up there knows what was going on. A public statement released by Rae and Jenny's children said, The last two years have seen our family caught in an agonising and exhausting limbo, desperate for answers and for closure. We urge anyone with information to please come forward and bring our family some peace.
在假期露营或经过该地区。这是你能在这个星球上找到的最偏远的地区之一。当时在该地区的人并不多。上面有人知道发生了什么。”雷和珍妮的孩子们发表的一份公开声明说：“过去两年，我们的家庭陷入了一种痛苦和疲惫的困境，渴望答案和了结。我们敦促任何有信息的人站出来，给我们的家庭带来一些平静。”
With no breakthroughs by mid-2018, police submitted an application to the Director of Public Prosecutions recommending that charges be laid against Graham Milne. The request was denied. By this point, Ray and Jenny's loved ones had spent over three years desperate for answers. Ray and Jenny's loved ones had spent over three years desperate for answers. That year was especially difficult for another reason. After Ray and Jenny first went missing, their beloved Great Dane Ella went to live with one of Jenny's daughters. Ella would often join the family at the Kelletts farm as they conducted routine maintenance on the property. She lived a good life before passing away in 2018 surrounded by family at the age of 12, a monumental age for a dog of her breed. For Ray's brother Dave, the fact that Ella lived so long was an indication of how big her heart was and how loved she'd been. But it was
到2018年中期仍无突破，警方提交了一份申请给公诉署，建议对格雷厄姆·米尔恩提起指控。该请求被拒绝。此时，雷和珍妮的亲人已经渴望答案超过三年了。雷和珍妮的亲人已经渴望答案超过三年了。那一年因为另一个原因而显得格外艰难。在雷和珍妮最初失踪后，他们心爱的大丹犬埃拉去和珍妮的一个女儿住在一起。埃拉经常在凯莱特夫妇的农场进行日常维护时加入家庭。它在2018年去世前过着美好的生活，在家人陪伴下享年12岁，对于它这个品种的狗来说，这是一个里程碑式的年龄。对于雷的兄弟戴夫（Dave）来说，埃拉活了这么久的事实表明它的心有多大，它有多受宠爱。但这也是
also a stark reminder that yet another significant event had passed by without Ray and Jenny's presence. To this day, no one knows exactly how Ella managed to get from the Kellett's campsite at Bell Chambers to the Sandstone Caravan Park 30 kilometres away. She was seen at the Kellett's campsite at Bell Chambers to the Sandstone Caravan Park 30 kilometres away. She was seen at the Kellett's campsite the day before she appeared in Sandstone, meaning she'd made the journey within a relatively short window of time. It would have been a huge walk for an older Great Dane, yet her paws didn't show any signs of trauma. Police remain open to the possibility that someone could have picked Ella up and dropped her off, yet if that was the case,
一个鲜明的提醒，又一个重要的事件在没有雷和珍妮在场的情况下过去了。直到今天，没有人确切知道埃拉是如何从贝尔钱伯斯的凯莱特营地到达30公里外的桑德斯通房车公园的。它在出现在桑德斯通的前一天被看到在凯莱特营地，这意味着它在相对较短的时间内完成了这段旅程。对于一只年长的大丹犬来说，这将是一段巨大的步行路程，但它的爪子没有显示出任何创伤的迹象。警方仍然对有人可能捡到埃拉并把它放下这一可能性持开放态度，但如果是这样的话，
nobody has ever come forward to say so. With no breakthroughs in the case by the start of 2020, a coronial inquest was held in a bid to determine exactly what happened to the couple. It provided a glimmer of hope for Ray and Jenny's loved ones, who described their experience over the past five years in a statement delivered to the court. It read in part, Ray and Jenny did not get to celebrate their 50th birthdays, nor will they share their dreams of spending more time together doing all that they loved in the great outdoors. Ray's eldest daughter has also given birth to a daughter and son. These are but only a handful
从来没有人站出来承认。到2020年初，案件仍无突破，为了确定这对夫妇到底发生了什么，举行了死因研讯。这为雷和珍妮的亲人带来了一线希望，他们在提交给法庭的声明中描述了他们过去五年的经历。声明部分写道：“雷和珍妮没能庆祝他们的50岁生日，他们也不会分享他们梦想的未来，即花更多时间在一起，做他们热爱的一切户外活动。雷的长女也生下了一个女儿和一个儿子。这些只是
of items in a kaleidoscope of moments and memories that will never be theirs. Depression has hit many of us severely. The impact this last five years has had on us as a family cannot be measured. There is no guidebook for how to traverse this incident and subsequent ordeal. Ray and Jenny were a compassionate, hard-working couple who were deeply loved by their family, friends, and community. All we want is to see that justice is served for Ray and that Jenny can be finally located so she can be laid to rest. We will not give up until this can be achieved." By this point, Graham Milne had provided four official statements and been interviewed by the police twice. It was not the role of the coroner to decide whether any
万花筒般瞬间和记忆中的一小部分，永远不会属于他们。抑郁症严重打击了我们许多人。这五年对我们家庭的影响是无法衡量的。对于如何度过这一事件及随后的磨难，没有指南。雷和珍妮是一对富有同情心、勤劳的夫妇，深受家人、朋友和社区的爱戴。我们想要的只是看到雷的正义得到伸张，珍妮能最终被找到，这样她就能入土为安。在实现这一目标之前，我们不会放弃。”此时，格雷厄姆·米尔恩已经提供了四份正式声明，并接受了警方两次采访。死因裁判官的角色不是决定是否
charges should be pursued against him, but simply to go on a fact-finding mission to determine how each death had occurred. Given that Graham Milne was the last person to see Ray and Jenny alive, his evidence was deemed vital, but when he was called to attend the inquest, he declined to speak on the grounds that anything he said could be used to incriminate him. The Western Australian Police Force confirmed that while Graham Milne remained their only person of interest in the case, they had no present intention to charge him. The coroner therefore compelled him to give evidence, deeming it vital for the ends of justice. Milne agreed to do so on the grounds that any answers he gave couldn't be used to prosecute him later on.
应该对他提起任何指控，而只是进行事实调查，以确定每起死亡是如何发生的。鉴于格雷厄姆·米尔恩是最后一个见到雷和珍妮活着的人，他的证据被认为至关重要，但当他被传唤参加研讯时，他以任何言论都可能被用来指控自己为由拒绝发言。西澳大利亚警察部队证实，虽然格雷厄姆·米尔恩仍然是他们案中唯一的利益相关者，但他们目前没有起诉他的打算。因此，死因裁判官强迫他提供证据，认为这对司法公正至关重要。米尔恩同意这样做，前提是他给出的任何答案都不能在以后被用来起诉他。
The coroner agreed to grant him a certificate of immunity only if she was satisfied that he responded appropriately to all the questions presented to him. Appearing on day eight of the inquest, Milne subsequently maintained that the trio had no intention of absailing down any mineshafts during their prospecting trip to Bell Chambers, nor did they bring any equipment that would allow them to do so. He testified that he'd never gone anywhere near the mineshaft where Ray's body was found. Asked how a cigarette butt with his DNA on it could have gotten three metres from the mine entrance, Milne suggested it could have been transferred there on the soles of the shoes of a member of the search party – an explanation the coroner found improbable.
死因裁判官同意只有在她确信他适当地回答了所有提出的问题时，才授予他豁免证书。在研讯的第八天出庭时，米尔恩随后坚持认为，三人组在前往贝尔钱伯斯的探矿旅行中没有进行任何绳降矿井的打算，也没有携带任何允许他们这样做的设备。他作证说，他从未去过发现雷遗体的矿井附近。当被问及一个带有他DNA的烟头怎么会出现在距离矿井入口三米远的地方时，米尔恩暗示它可能是被搜救队成员鞋底带到那里的——死因裁判官认为这种解释不太可能。
When asked why he didn't tell the police about the mud map they found in Jenny's luggage, Milne said he'd forgotten they'd overdrawn it. He denied allegations that it was a map to the mineshaft containing Ray's body and maintained it referenced a crystal mineshaft that Jenny was interested in, which he claimed was higher up and to the left of the mine where Ray was found. Milne also denied that he'd intentionally led the police away from the mine when he took them southeast of the camp during their initial search. Mark and Georgina Granville testified to seeing a man matching Graham Milne's appearance on the
当被问及为什么他不告诉警方他们在珍妮行李中发现的泥图时，米尔恩说他忘了他们画过它。他否认了这是通往包含雷遗体的矿井的地图的指控，并坚持认为它指的是珍妮感兴趣的一个水晶矿井，他声称该矿井位于雷被发现的矿井上方和左侧。米尔恩还否认了他在最初搜寻时将警方带到营地东南方时是故意引导他们远离矿井的。马克和乔治娜·格兰维尔作证说，看到一个外貌与格雷厄姆·米尔恩相符的男子在
Paynes Find to Sandstone Road in the early morning hours of Sunday March 22, 2015. They described his four-wheel drive as having a trailer attached to it which contained a quad bike. The quad bike was facing east-west, the opposite direction to which the man's vehicle was travelling. However, Graham Milne pointed out that his quad bike could not be placed in an East-West direction on his trailer, only North-South. Various photographs were submitted to support this, although police have not confirmed whether they investigated the possibility that Milne could have used a different trailer on the weekend in question. The inquest also explored the possibility that Ray and Jenny's demise had resulted from an accident. A search and rescue expert testified that it was possible that
2015年3月22日星期日清晨，佩恩斯芬德（Paynes Find）通往桑德斯通（Sandstone）的路上。他们描述说，他的四驱车上拖着一辆拖车，上面装有一辆四轮摩托车。那辆四轮摩托车的朝向是东西向，与该男子车辆行驶的方向相反。然而，格雷厄姆·米尔恩（Graham Milne）指出，他的四轮摩托车无法在拖车上以东西向放置，只能南北向放置。为此提交了各种照片作为佐证，尽管警方尚未证实他们是否调查过米尔恩在那个周末可能使用了另一辆拖车的可能性。死因研讯还探讨了雷（Ray）和珍妮（Jenny）的死亡是由事故造成的可能性。一位搜救专家作证说，有可能
Ray had fallen down the shaft after chasing Ella while Jenny sat at the top of the shaft. Partners tend to stay together, he explained. Maybe she was hoping Ray would come too and they'd be able to work their way out of it. Had darkness quickly fallen, he said it was possible that Jenny had tried to find her way back to camp before getting lost and perishing. However, if that was the case, he said that Jenny's body would have been found. He also clarified that this theory was possible purely from a search and rescue viewpoint and did not take into account the possibility that a third party was involved. If the story about Ella running away to chase animals wasn't accurate, he said it would impact all other possible conclusions and quote, "...it's possible if that's incorrect,
雷在追赶埃拉（Ella）时掉进了矿井，而珍妮则坐在矿井口。他解释说，伴侣往往会待在一起。也许她当时希望雷也能上来，这样他们就能一起想办法脱困。他说，如果天黑得很快，珍妮有可能在迷路并遇难前试图找路回营地。然而，他说如果真是那样，珍妮的尸体应该已经被发现了。他还澄清说，这一理论纯粹是从搜救的角度来看是可能的，并没有考虑到第三方介入的可能性。他说，如果关于埃拉跑去追动物的故事不准确，那将影响所有其他可能的结论，并引用道：“……如果那是不正确的，那么
then everything that follows is incorrect." It was a long wait for Ray and Jenny's loved ones before the coroner delivered her findings in May the following year. She concluded that it couldn't be established that the person the Granvilles had seen had indeed been Graham Milne. However, she ruled out the possibility that Ray Kellett had fallen down the mineshaft by accident, citing various reasons, including the strange positioning of his quad bike some 500 metres away, and the fact that someone with Ray's experience wouldn't run through such an area without looking closely at where they were going.
随之而来的一切也都是不正确的。”在第二年五月验尸官公布调查结果之前，雷和珍妮的亲人们经历了漫长的等待。她得出结论，无法确定格兰维尔一家（Granvilles）所看到的人确实是格雷厄姆·米尔恩。然而，她排除了雷·凯莱特（Ray Kellett）因事故掉进矿井的可能性，并列举了各种原因，包括他的四轮摩托车在约500米外奇怪的停放位置，以及像雷这样有经验的人不会在不仔细观察前方道路的情况下就跑过那片区域的事实。
The coroner found that the evidence indicated Ray and Jenny intended to abseil into one or more mineshafts during their trip in the hopes of finding gold. Based on Ray's injuries, particularly his broken hyoid bone, the lack of skeletal injuries, and the blood on his boots and petrol can, the coroner concluded, I am satisfied that Ray came to harm at the base of the mineshaft. His death was violent and attributable to trauma from injury sustained as a result of the actions of a person or persons unknown. She was unable to say whether Ray died immediately or whether whoever killed him moved his body further into the mineshaft to conceal it, but concluded, "...I find that Rey's death occurred as a result of
验尸官发现，证据表明雷和珍妮在旅行期间打算进入一个或多个矿井进行速降，希望能找到黄金。根据雷的伤势，特别是他断裂的舌骨、缺乏骨骼损伤，以及靴子和汽油桶上的血迹，验尸官总结道：“我确信雷在矿井底部受到了伤害。他的死亡是暴力的，归因于身份不明的人或多人行为所造成的创伤。”她无法说明雷是立即死亡，还是杀害他的人为了掩盖罪行将他的尸体移到了矿井更深处，但她总结道：“……我认定雷的死亡是由于
homicide by a person or persons unknown." Without a body, the coroner concluded that it wasn't possible to determine how Jenny died, but she was satisfied that her remains were somewhere in the sandstone area. The coroner said it was possible that Jenny had sustained violent trauma, or had managed to escape immediate danger before becoming disoriented and lost. Either way, she was satisfied that both Ray and Jenny died on or around Sunday March 22, 2015, within a short time of one another. The coroner found that Graham Milne had answered all questions satisfactorily and granted his certificate of immunity. While her findings would be handed to the director of public prosecutions, the coroner clarified that she hadn't formed a belief concerning Milne's
身份不明的人或多人实施的谋杀。”由于没有尸体，验尸官得出结论，无法确定珍妮是如何死亡的，但她确信珍妮的遗骸就在桑德斯通地区。验尸官表示，珍妮有可能遭受了暴力创伤，或者在迷失方向并走失之前设法逃离了直接危险。无论如何，她确信雷和珍妮都在2015年3月22日星期日左右，在彼此相隔很短的时间内死亡。验尸官发现格雷厄姆·米尔恩满意地回答了所有问题，并授予了他豁免证书。虽然她的调查结果将移交给公诉署署长，但验尸官澄清说，她并未就米尔恩
potential involvement in any crime. Acknowledging the impact of the deaths, the coroner stated, The families of Ray and Jenny have suffered the loss of their loved ones in circumstances that are disturbing and unsettling. Their pain and grief is enduring. There has been a great deal of speculation as to the circumstances of their deaths, and whilst this may be unavoidable in the context of these events, it carries the risk of compounding their stress and adding to their angst. Ray and Jenny were greatly loved and deeply respected by their families.
是否可能卷入任何犯罪形成定论。在承认这些死亡事件的影响时，验尸官表示：“雷和珍妮的家人在令人不安和困扰的情况下失去了亲人。他们的痛苦和悲伤是持久的。关于他们死亡的情况有大量的猜测，虽然在这些事件的背景下这可能是不可避免的，但这带有加剧他们压力并增加他们焦虑的风险。雷和珍妮深受家人的爱戴和深切的尊重。”
Their deaths are a loss to their loved ones and to the community. The findings provoked mixed feelings for Ray and Jenny's children. The findings provoked mixed feelings for Ray and Jenny's children. A statement released on their behalf said, "...the last six years have been a torturous existence of uncertainty and grief. Questions left unanswered and speculation from strangers have left us all aching in ways that are beyond description. We are vindicated and heartbroken in equal measure that the coroner shares our understanding of events. It's beyond belief that anyone would ever want to hurt such loving, generous souls, and we call the justice to be served for our mother and father. and father. It took another 13 months before the Director of Public Prosecutions returned their verdict. By June 2022, over seven years had passed since Ray and Jenny's deaths and still no
他们的离世对他们的亲人和社区来说都是一种损失。调查结果在雷和珍妮的孩子们中引发了复杂的情绪。一份代表他们发表的声明称：“……过去六年是充满不确定性和悲伤的折磨。未解的问题和陌生人的猜测让我们所有人都感到难以言表的痛苦。验尸官与我们对事件的理解一致，这既让我们感到平反，也让我们心碎。令人难以置信的是，竟然有人会想要伤害如此充满爱心、慷慨的灵魂，我们呼吁为我们的母亲和父亲伸张正义。”又过了13个月，公诉署署长才给出了他们的裁决。到2022年6月，距离雷和珍妮去世已经过去了七年多，但仍然
one had been held accountable. Based on the inquest findings and the evidence at hand, the DPP ruled that no charges would be laid. A statement released on their behalf said, In this case, all the evidence was closely examined by some of the most senior prosecutors in the state who determined that there are no reasonable prospects of conviction on the available evidence. While the Western Australian police said the investigation remained active and ongoing, the decision came as a major blow to Ray and to Jenny's families. But they weren't the only ones shocked by it. In 2023, a panel of experts gathered to review
没有人被追究责任。根据死因研讯的结果和现有的证据，公诉署裁定不予起诉。一份代表他们发表的声明称：“在本案中，州内一些最高级别的检察官仔细审查了所有证据，他们确定根据现有证据，没有合理的定罪前景。”虽然西澳大利亚警方表示调查仍然活跃且在进行中，但这一决定对雷和珍妮的家人来说是一个重大打击。但他们并不是唯一对此感到震惊的人。2023年，一个专家小组聚集在一起审查
the Kellett case for an episode of Channel 9's Under Investigation with Liz Hayes. They unanimously agreed that the case should be re-examined by prosecutors. A renowned criminal barrister appeared on the show and said, criminal barrister appeared on the show and said, In my view, it should have been left to members of the community, namely a jury assisted by properly qualified experts and a thorough investigation to make their determination about what actually happened. And it's a sad thing that that hasn't occurred. Forensic scientist Dr Mark Reynolds, who had worked on the case in the early days, also served on the panel. He'd been pressing for Ray's death to be treated as a homicide from
凯莱特案，用于第九频道《正在调查》（Under Investigation）节目的一集，由莉兹·海耶斯（Liz Hayes）主持。他们一致认为，检察官应该重新审查此案。一位著名的刑事大律师在节目中出现并表示：“在我看来，应该留给社区成员，即由合格专家协助的陪审团，通过彻底的调查来确定到底发生了什么。没能做到这一点是一件令人悲哀的事情。”曾在早期参与此案的法医马克·雷诺兹（Mark Reynolds）博士也加入了该小组。他一直敦促将雷的死亡视为谋杀案来处理，从
the moment his body was found. Dr Reynolds was particularly interested in the injury to Ray's cheekbone, in which a 3-4mm piece of bone had become dislodged. In his experience, Dr Reynolds told under investigation that this could be indicative of a gunshot wound, possibly from Ray's own rifle. No forensic evidence has ever been presented to confirm Milne's story about why two bullets were missing from Ray's rifle. Ray's family believes he would never have fired shots into the open country knowing that other people were in the area.
发现他尸体的那一刻起。雷诺兹博士对雷颧骨上的伤口特别感兴趣，那里有一块3-4毫米的骨头脱落了。雷诺兹博士根据经验告诉《正在调查》节目，这可能预示着枪伤，可能来自雷自己的步枪。从未有法医证据证实米尔恩关于雷的步枪中为何少了子弹的故事。雷的家人认为，如果知道附近有其他人，他绝不会向开阔的乡村开枪。
Dr Reynolds explained, We've got two gunshots, we have a firearm, we have two victims, and two rounds missing. Former homicide detective Damien Loon stated, Unfortunately, my belief would be that a firearm has been used in this case. A man identified only as Rick was a former reconnaissance expert in the Australian army who had also worked for the State Emergency Service. After watching the under-investigation episode, Rick felt compelled to help. He travelled to Sandstone and used his expertise to search the area. Over a month, he uncovered about a dozen other items he thought could hold
雷诺兹博士解释说：“我们有两声枪响，我们有一件武器，我们有两名受害者，还有两发子弹缺失。”前凶杀案侦探达米安·伦（Damien Loon）表示：“不幸的是，我的看法是本案中使用了枪支。”一名仅被确认为“里克”（Rick）的男子是澳大利亚军队的前侦察专家，也曾为州紧急服务部门工作。在观看了《正在调查》的那一集后，里克感到有责任提供帮助。他前往桑德斯通，利用自己的专业知识搜寻该地区。在一个月的时间里，他发现了大约十几件他认为可能具有
relevance to the Kellett case. He then decided to venture into the mineshaft where Ray Kellett's body was found. After just 10 minutes down the hole, Rick found an item of clothing buried under the dirt. His collection was handed to the police and in June 2023, a special crime squad returned to the site to conduct a major excavation of the old mineshaft on the hunt for any clues that could be hidden underneath the rubble. Speaking about Rick's find, the West Australian Police Commissioner said he could neither confirm nor deny whether the shirt had anything to do with the Kellets case. We can't say it is. We can't say it isn't, he remarked. If Rick or the Special Crime Squad uncovered anything significant during these searches,
与凯莱特案相关性的物品。随后，他决定冒险进入发现雷·凯莱特尸体的矿井。在洞里待了仅仅10分钟后，里克就发现了一件埋在泥土下的衣物。他的收藏品被移交给了警方，2023年6月，一个特别犯罪小组回到了现场，对旧矿井进行了大规模挖掘，搜寻可能隐藏在瓦砾下的任何线索。在谈到里克的发现时，西澳大利亚警察局长表示，他既不能证实也不能否认这件衬衫是否与凯莱特案有关。他评论道：“我们不能说它是，也不能说它不是。”如果里克或特别犯罪小组在这些搜寻过程中发现了任何重大线索，
it hasn't been publicly revealed. However, a blog post written by Ray's brother Dave in 2024, on the 9th anniversary of the Kellett's ill-fated prospecting trip, said, Much has happened this last year since. Much is happening. Dave's blog, titled Man in the Hole, provides an open and honest account of his family's experience in their quest for justice. Dave is vocal about his disappointment in the police handling of Ray and Jenny's case. In his view, investigators erred by initially treating Ray into Jenny's case as two tourists lost in the countryside, even when information provided early on from the family and locals indicated something
目前尚未公开披露。然而，雷的兄弟戴夫（Dave）在2024年，即凯莱特那次不幸的探矿之旅9周年之际写的一篇博客文章中说：“去年以来发生了很多事。很多事情正在发生。”戴夫的博客题为《洞中的人》（Man in the Hole），对他家人在寻求正义过程中的经历进行了公开和诚实的描述。戴夫直言不讳地表达了他对警方处理雷和珍妮案件方式的失望。在他看来，调查人员最初将雷和珍妮的案件视为两名在乡村迷路的游客，这犯了错误，即使当时家人和当地人提供的早期信息表明有
more sinister was at play. For Dave and his brother Malcolm, it's memories of Ray at his country boy finest that will always be held dearest. From a very young age, the three brothers were allowed to take the family's old Land Rover and head out bush to hunt feral animals. Ray would always be the driver, even though he could barely see over the steering wheel, his two brothers standing on the back tray and giving directions while Ray chuckled with delight. Ray's ashes were scattered around his farm just like he would have wanted. The only thing missing is Jenny. While Jenny's children
更险恶的事情在发生。对于戴夫和他的兄弟马尔科姆（Malcolm）来说，雷作为乡村男孩最美好的一面将永远被珍藏在记忆中。从很小的时候起，这三个兄弟就被允许开着家里那辆旧路虎车去丛林里猎杀野兽。雷总是司机，尽管他几乎看不见方向盘上方，他的两个兄弟站在后车厢上指路，而雷则开心地咯咯笑。雷的骨灰像他所希望的那样撒在了他的农场周围。唯一缺少的是珍妮。虽然珍妮的孩子们
want to see justice served for whoever killed their mother and stepfather, the thing they want most of all is to find Jenny's body so they can scatter her ashes with rays. It's a continual source of pain for them knowing that the inseparable couple have been kept apart. Jenny's youngest daughter told journalist Caroline Overington in the documentary Murder in the Goldfields, At this point, it's not even about putting someone behind bars or getting a conviction, it's just about getting mum. We just want to bring her home. As far as Jenny's children are concerned, the only way that will ever happen is if someone who knows
想要为杀害他们母亲和继父的人伸张正义，但他们最想要的是找到珍妮的尸体，这样他们就可以把她的骨灰和雷的撒在一起。知道这对形影不离的夫妇被分开，对他们来说是一种持续的痛苦。珍妮最小的女儿在纪录片《金矿区的谋杀案》（Murder in the Goldfields）中告诉记者卡罗琳·奥弗林顿（Caroline Overington）：“在这一点上，这甚至不是关于把某人关进监狱或获得定罪，这只是关于找回妈妈。我们只想带她回家。”就珍妮的孩子们而言，唯一能实现这一目标的途径就是如果有人知道
the truth decides to come forward. One told under investigation with Liz Hayes, she's never going to be found without a bit of honesty and that's what I want. Case file makes no allegations of guilt against Graham Milne. Anyone with information is encouraged to contact Crimestoppers on 1800 333 000. Investigators are particularly interested in hearing from anyone who passed through the Sandstone area and surrounding outback in the critical time period between Wednesday March 18 and Sunday March 22, 2015. Any dashcam footage or seemingly insignificant detail could prove crucial. The occupants of the white four-wheel drive Graham Milne claimed to see in the area shortly before the Kellett's disappearance have never come forward. The reward for information
真相并决定站出来。其中一人告诉《正在调查》节目，没有一点诚实，她永远不会被找到，而这就是我想要的。本案档案不对格雷厄姆·米尔恩提出任何有罪指控。鼓励任何有信息的人拨打1800 333 000联系灭罪热线。调查人员特别希望听到任何在2015年3月18日星期三至3月22日星期日这一关键时期经过桑德斯通地区及周边内陆地区的人的消息。任何行车记录仪录像或看似微不足道的细节都可能至关重要。格雷厄姆·米尔恩声称在凯莱特失踪前不久在附近看到的白色四驱车的乘员从未露面。悬赏信息
that leads to a conviction in the Kellett case has been increased to $1 million, with the reward applying to both Ray and Jenny individually. That means $2 million is available for anyone who provides the missing key. For locals in the Sandstone area, Jenny Kellett is never far from their mines when they go out prospecting. Some have dedicated hours of their spare time searching for Jenny down the old mineshafts in the area. To this day, many locals continue to look out for her as they traverse the remote red earth in search of gold. The manager of the Sandstone pub told the ABC, Sandstone has never forgotten Jenny and Ray. We always look for her if we're out in the bush.
导致凯莱特案定罪的悬赏金已增加到100万美元，悬赏金分别适用于雷和珍妮。这意味着任何人如果能提供缺失的关键线索，将获得200万美元的奖励。对于桑德斯通地区的当地人来说，当他们出去探矿时，珍妮·凯莱特从未远离他们的思绪。有些人投入了数小时的业余时间在当地的旧矿井中搜寻珍妮。直到今天，许多当地人在穿越偏远的红土地寻找黄金时，仍在继续寻找她。桑德斯通酒吧的经理告诉澳大利亚广播公司（ABC）：“桑德斯通从未忘记珍妮和雷。如果我们去丛林，我们总是会寻找她。”
Former homicide investigator Damien Loon believes that Jenny's body is the key they need to solve the puzzle. He told under investigation, we find Jenny, we will find out what happened and why. The other experts on the panel agreed, with Dr Mark Reynolds remarking, it's probably the only K we've got left. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
前凶杀案调查员达米安·伦认为，珍妮的尸体是他们解开谜题所需的关键。他告诉《正在调查》节目：“我们找到珍妮，我们就会查明发生了什么以及原因。”小组中的其他专家表示同意，马克·雷诺兹博士评论道：“这可能是我们剩下的唯一关键了。”本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。